e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission qui vous
oblige à regarder la télé avec nous ce
soir
le studio a accusé de terrorisme par les
américains jodie dit
klaus mon corps j'ai bien
isabelle alonso le juge halphen
luc romero ouais
ge dans le col de magal
à
selenis des jours et la probable blind
test consacré ce soir c'est normal en ce
début d'année à la bonne aventure
[Applaudissements]
ah la la
à
la voilà
[Applaudissements]
là
ouais
je vous demande de vous arrêter ouais
[Musique]
alors basse tout de suite aux premiers
invités la sphère dont tout le monde
parle
souvenez-vous magnéto serge le fbi a ils
soupçonnent votre fils d'être l'auteur
des messages terroristes trouvé dans les
toilettes est bien pire on l'accuse de
menace d'utilisation d'armes de
destruction massive pour anéantir les
états unis c'est à peine croyable chaire
est totalement fou alors vous l'appelez
vous à ce moment là vous l'avez au
téléphone et vous vous vous lui dites
est ce que c'est toi qui a fait le coup
tout à fait et là ils vous répondent non
et vous êtes sûr vous êtes vraiment sûr
que il vous aurait pas raconter
d'histoire n'ont donc vous partez aux
états unis et pour payer la peau payer
la caution 250 mille dollars
vous avez fait comment pour les trouver
il fonds de tiroirs et les amis c'est
difficile mais on va y arriver quand je
suis allé le sortir de là votre fils
bien sûr voilà cet homme qui pleure
c'est le père du soir d'y penser
accusé de terrorisme par les américains
voici michael philippe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mais c'est ce bon soir soit la
bienvenue en france un merci ça se fête
le
oh
[Musique]
où
alors après neuf mois de cauchemar aux
états unis vous êtes rentré en france
michael 21 décembre dernier pour un bon
noël
j'imagine un excellent excellent noël
qui vous a sorti de là ce sont mes
avocats
ouais monsieur le président de la
république votre aide et l'aide de tous
les français aussi
bah voilà bon on applaudit
alors commence il ya près d'un an donc
vous êtes stewart sur le vol londres
orlando de la compagnie virgin atlantic
où vous travaillez depuis deux ans et
dans les toilettes vous découvrez une
inscription à la fois sur un sac en
papier est à la fois sur le miroir des
toilettes
ben laden est le meilleur les américains
doivent mourir
et puis une autre inscription il y a une
bombe à bord signés al-qaïda voile alors
vous prévenez le commandant de bord bien
entendu l'avion est détournée sur age à
vic en islande
l'avion est fouillé on trouve rien du
tout dans dans cet avion et deux mois
plus tard alors que vous êtes dans un
des aéroports de new york qui s'appelle
new york
vous êtes arrêté et accusé de menace
d'utilisation d'armes de destruction
massive contre les états unis
motif il ya écrit ben laden ben plus
loin laden et les américains eux
écrivent bin laden ben l adn c'est à
dire que vous êtes le seul français à
bord et vous êtes le seul qui auriez pu
écrire finalement ben laden comme ça que
les autres leurs écrits b n en fait pas
du tout puisque ça ce n'est jamais sorti
lors de l'audience nombreuses audiences
jamais personne n'a parlé de ça pour la
simple et bonne raison que j'ai trouvé
grâce à odos graphologue américains que
nous avons menées qui sont les deux
meilleurs des états unis tout simplement
des journaux comme le new york times qui
écrivait ben ben ouais et laden laden un
ouais le canton aux états unis on écrit
aussi ben laden en fait il n'y a aucune
façon de l'écrire puisque donc ça le
juge a toujours dit je peux même pas
l'entendre bien alors vous avez été mis
en prison pour vous sortir de prison
il a fallu que votre père hamas la somme
de 500 mille dollars c'est pas rien il
est venu ici nous en parlait d'ailleurs
les difficultés qui l'avaient votre père
pour réunir cette somme vous avez été
mis en résidence surveillée au sein
d'une famille américaine avec un
bracelet électronique alors racontez
nous parce qu'ici en a pas comment ça se
passe donc en fait c'est tout bêtement
un système qui permet aux autorités
judiciaires d'avoir toujours le contrôle
sur moi ouais donc c'est à dire c'est
comme une balise comme un gps
ouais et ils savent exactement où je
suis quand je suis et il ya une borne
qui était dans ma maison il fallait que
je rentre à 18 heures tous les soirs
et si jamais à 18h01 je n'étais pas là
c'est le retour en prison direct away
dont il y avait une alerte automatique
c'était automatique ouais alors ici vos
parents ameute les médias me que les
hommes politiques
c'est vrai que jacques chirac a
téléphoné à george bush jacques chirac a
téléphoné je ne sais pas mais à est
intervenu auprès de son homologue
américain
j'ai bien débrouillé oui je crois que le
président de la république a non
seulement écrit à george bush
mais lors de rencontres je crois sur le
sommet de l'otan
il a également une discussion et puis je
crois que le président de la république
a été ému par ce que si une affaire
tellement stupide aberrante et que c'est
un ressortissant français
et les choses ne vont pas s'arrêter là
ouais on espère que jacques chirac en
fera autant pour michaël blanc qui était
en prison à perpétuité à bali pour 1 kg
de shit quand même jack fait quelque
chose alors le problème c'est que pour
sortir de là la seule solution pour vous
en fait ça a été de plaider coupable
j'ai pris une peine de cinq ans avec
sursis dont vous avez pu rentrer en
france
et sinon si vous n'aviez pas accepter
l'arrangement vous risquez 15 ans de
taule voilà c'est simple pour un ré prix
donc dans un coin c'était 15 ans de
prison ferme
ou alors 5 ans de prison avec sursis et
la possibilité surtout de rentrer en
france
ouais c'est très dur à admettre comme
marcher parce que quand on n'est pas
coupable
être obligé d'admettre qu'on l'ait pour
pouvoir partir c'est terrible non
c'est intolérable c'est le système
américain c'est à dire qu'ils se
comportent comme des cow boys et puis
lorsqu'ils ont mis la pression sur des
personnes qu'elles sont complètement la
tête dans l'eau eh bien on leur dit
écoutez on veut bien vous sortir un tout
petit peu la tête
éventuellement le corps et vous accepté
de passer par ce que nous vous demandons
pour qu'aujourd'hui
michael effectivement il a plaidé
coupable aux états unis mais il a
dénoncé dès qu'il est arrivé cette
situation et puis je crois qu'il n'en
restera pas là
il ya eu des faux témoignages contre
michael aux états unis il y a également
eu des des contraintes des pressions
pour que michael puisse plaider coupable
nous allons très certainement déposer
plainte à la fois pour faux témoignage
et puis pour extorsion ouais alors
aujourd'hui michael vous êtes sans
emploi et virgin vous réclame alors ça
c'est incroyable ils vous réclame 100 76
mille dollars à cause du préjudice subi
par leurs compagnies aériennes sellam
incroyable oui c'est incroyable
en fait c'est surtout le juge kim a
condamné à cette restitution
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya pas bien
jean n'a rien mis en oeuvre en tout cas
aujourd'hui pour que je rembourse cette
somme vous diriez quoi michael à cet
agent du fbi qui vous a tellement
harcelée comme ça je crois je te vois
que c'est une pratique complètement
scandaleuse et que je suis là pour dire
que les états unis et le système
américain judiciaire américain est
scandaleux cet agent du fbi a monté de
fausses preuves contre moi par exemple
par exemple c'est faux témoignages de
prisonniers qui m'accusait d'être un
super agent secret des services français
et de l'autre côté de prendre 3 grammes
de cocaïne
ce que je peux vous dire c'est un peu et
donc cet agent du fbi ya monté de toutes
pièces ces témoignages et j'ai
aujourd'hui la preuve qu'il aurait
soi-disant interrogèrent des prisonniers
et avec la date ne concordent pas
puisque ce prisonnier était en route
vers l'autre bout des états unis dans l
avion des marshals d'accord donc ça ça
coince mais malheureusement j'ai eu les
pièces du dossier qu'après que je
voulais les coupables ouais c'est assez
un peu brisé
l'idée que vous faisiez des états unis
quand même cette histoire non oui oui on
pense le fbi y aille
on associe le fbi avec x files c'est
vraiment le sbf je pense qu'ils sont
bons à tourner des films c'est tout un
niveau de la police ou à créer des
fausses preuves
merci merci beaucoup
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
pour la campagne
ils financeraient penya els moisson de
nuit qui lui va si bien dit il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va pas mal j'ai un vidéo sampler si
des fois quelque chose qui vous plaît
pas voilà ce que se passerait c'est
lamentable
celle-là ça vous évitera de répéter
comme ça d'un coup sûr fois pendant
l'émission joffrin claque moustoir
contre eux pensent qu'il faut le passer
et si vous êtes vraiment bon je ferai ça
mais ça certes c'est un moment de tv il
ya alors regarder si vous êtes considéré
comme le séducteur du cinéma français
l'homme dans tous les cas c'est tout de
suite le match
allez-y c'est la mort l'homme dont on
rêve toutes les femmes gravity oui et
c'est vrai qu'à part vous qui est le
séducteur du cinéma français je pensais
à ça en préparant cette interview je me
dis à papa arditi et moi aussi je me le
demandait je ne voyais vraiment pas
qu'ils pouvaient tenir banon la samoa
vous faites bien de le dire mais je
tiens à le préciser oui à part vous qui
a votre physique avant la personne
j'espère à part vous pierre qui peut
jouer en attendant godot de beckett et
joyeuses pâques de poiret il y en a il y
en a mais n'ont pas déçu mes filles en a
j'ai un truc pour ce que je suis en
train de faire
je vais l'offrir drucker il s'en servira
plus que moi alors à part vous c'est con
à part vous qui faut-il aller voir au
théâtre en ce moment il ya des tas de
choses
oui je vois je vais vous dire je vous
dise il fallait voir une très belle
pièce qui s'appelle la preuve
ouais que avec anouk grinberg avec anouk
grinberg malheureusement maintenant je
crois qu'à nous grimbert va va être
remplacé mais ce n'est pas grave la
pièce est magnifique elle était
formidable d'ailleurs et tout le monde
et c'est michel aumont qui va remplacer
rufus avec pas mal non plus très belle
place alors dites-moi pierre à part vous
qui pourrait remplacer christian clavier
dans la série x 3 pas grand monde
je vois pas normal en plus ça
honnêtement la joie des comptes à quel
point vous êtes unique à part vous qui a
eu le privilège d'être second rôle
derrière bernard tapie voulez-vous me
repasser
fantasme de catherine barma vous bonnes
réponses
bon c'est la godasse yves allons-y voilà
très bien plus sérieusement à part vous
qui était à la fiche de une leçon de
savoir-vivre de jean claude grumberg au
théâtre du rond-point à 18h30 jusqu'au
18 janvier
perso personnes s'intéressant en plus à
un monologue
donc vous êtes seul en scène et voilà
alors ça pouvait être que vous là non ça
aurait pu être des tas d'autres gens
enfin il se trouve que jean claude
grumberg m'a demandé à moi de dire ce
texte et j'ai accepté avec plaisir et
intérêt à saint-ex qui est écrit par
grimbert à partir des conseils donnés
par des médecins sous l'occupation pour
apprendre aux gens à dire du mal des
juifs en toute impunité c'est ça
l'histoire l'histoire c'est à partir de
ces textes qui ont été écrits en
particulier en 1940 par un docteur qui
s'appelait docteur montandon et qui a
établi toute une théorie de signes
distinctifs pour bien reconnaître et
identifier le juif c'est à dire les
juifs textes qui sont absolument
impensable dont on n'ose pas imaginer le
contenu et que c'est que je vais lire
d'ailleurs effectivement de ces textes
sont nés les doigts les lois anti juives
de l'occupation alors grimbert avec sa
causticité naturelle lui à transformer
ça en une leçon savoir vivre et le
chapitre traité c'est la fin de repas
c'est à dire que j'avais de fabre passé
sinon c'est difficile ça peut tout se
passe bien puis tout d'un coup un mot
déplacé une attitude qui peut être
irrévérencieuse et ça vous fout de repas
en l'air voilà et pourquoi ça vous fout
leur part en l'air parce que bon au
début du repas pour mettre de l'ambiance
vous aviez vous aviez
fait une petite plaisanterie sur les
[ __ ] alors bon ça n'avait pas
déclenché l'hilarité générale
j'ai senti que les gens ne s'est pas
totalement hostile et au milieu du repas
vous y êtes allé sur votre que que sur
votre couplet sur les [ __ ] là non
plus
bon on vous a pas taper dessus mais vous
savez bien senti que les gens ne te pas
malveillant votre égard et donc tout
naturellement en fin de repas vous en
venez tout naturellement à dire avoir ce
besoin bien légitime de dire du mal des
juifs et à ce moment là le mec qui est
en face de vous vous balance son verre
de mouton rothschild 87 à la gueule
parce qu'il l'est qui ne supporte pas
que et que et à partir de cette manière
de tourner en dérision quelque chose qui
est absolument immonde grimbert retombe
sur ces fameux texte et lui tourne ça sa
manière c'est à dire écoutez si vous
voulez pouvoir continuer de dire du mal
des juifs en public en toute impunité
assurez vous d'abord que vous n'êtes pas
en face d'un juif donc le seul moyen de
le savoir ces deux qu'on vous donne les
points d'europe de repérage pour être
absolument certains vous êtes en face de
quelqu'un qui ne l'est pas après
évidemment on tombe sur l'infamie la
plus totale qui n'est pas que je suis à
d'ailleurs quand il s'agit de jusque
quand il s'agit bien sûr de [ __ ] comme
on le dit ou d'arabes
comme on le dit c'est toujours la même
chose c'est à dire c'est la haine de
l'autre
quoi voilà donc ça s'appelle une leçon
de savoir vivre
c'est au théâtre du rond point tous les
soirs à 18h30
la gym question la question de lionel
jospin
[Musique]
pierre arditi
oui si ces représentations sont un échec
est-ce que vous assumerait pleinement la
responsabilité de cet échec
est-ce que vous en tirez les conclusions
en vous retirant de la vie théâtrale
après le 18 janvier voulez vous me
passez imité par le petit je savais que
ça servirait je savais ça vous évite de
le faire oui alors vous avez des
souvenirs de la lecture parce que quand
vous étiez enfant votre tante vous lisez
des livres à voix haute pierre arditi
parce que vous n'arriviez pas à vous
endormir vous aviez le sentiment que si
vous endormir vous vous réveillera
jamais quoi c'était comme mourir pour
vous sans dormir
c'est surtout parce que j'avais le
sentiment qu'on me ce qu'on me privait
de vie ouais c'est dire comme mes yeux
devaient se faire mais je voyais plus de
monde
et puis au bout d'un moment contraint
forcé par ma grand mère par ma mère par
toute la famille de dormir à une heure
où personne ne dort c'est absolument
déraisonnable de faire dormir
quelqu'un dans la journée un enfant
stampede pire que tout alors j'ai fini
par la force de mad de mon énergie et de
mon refus de fermer les yeux de les
fermer tout de même j'ai découvert que
j'entendais tout de même le bruit de la
vie à cette époque là on habitait place
wagram sur la place et alors il y avait
le boulevard pereire et puis la place et
puis il y avait la petite ceinture qui
passait le long de l'immeuble
et puis les autobus avec cette
merveilleuse chasse qui ressemblait au
chalet zabouri formidable que vous aurez
la petite machine du poinçonneur qui
oblitère elle trucks avec j'entendais
tout ça est un monde à lui je me suis
mais c'est magnifique au fond je peux
fermer les yeux
c'est encore plus beau quand je les ai
ouvert parce que là je peux repeindre le
monde comme j'en ai envie
imaginez la couleur de l'autobus je peux
rien imaginer ça marche peut imaginer
que les vitesses grince parce qu'une
voiture qui l'empêchent de passer et
j'ai rock refabriquer reconstituer le
monde avec mon imaginaire en fermant les
yeux et je ce livre que je dise que je
dis toujours que je finirais pas écrire
j'ai commencé d'ailleurs commence comme
ça par se souvenir de la vire créer tes
yeux fermés qui s'appelle le sommeil où
l'on ne meurt pas très bien ici on vous
souhaite de trouver le temps où vivaient
ensemble
c'est seulement du temps oui bien sûr
bien sûr alors là on a parlé de théâtre
bientôt on va voir dans un film qui
s'appelle le mystère de la chambre jaune
avec denis podalydès est un film de
bruno podalydès
avec sabine azéma alors après il y aura
un film d'alain resnais d'après une
opérette de maurice yvain qui s'appelle
pas sur la bouche
toujours avec sabine azéma oui alors la
télé ou fait toujours le personnage
récurrent de sauveur giordano sur tf1
ils n'ont pas de problème avec vous tf1
quand vous parlez de la télé parce que
vous êtes drôlement violon j'ai encore
entendu l'autre jour sur france inter ça
les embête pas tf1
non il ya des choses que fait tf1 que je
n'aime pas et je ne défends pas et il ya
des choses que le service public ne fait
pas et que ça m'emmerde qu'ils ne le
fassent pas voilà ce que vous pensez à
une émission lundi
lundi soir à 20h50 sur france 2 en prime
time
ça s'appelle tribu de l'âme messieurs
l'animateur est magnifique type génial
bien
alors pierre arditi oui thierry ardisson
oui
vous pourrez accueillir la guerre la
guerre quoi avec l'irak
on se pense pas quand même que la france
ait envie de jouer les va-t-en-guerre
d'ailleurs personne n'en a envie
même les anglais qui étaient très très
véhément derrière l'amérique ont l'air
de temporiser parce que il ya comme vous
le savez sans doute en regardant le
journal de votre chaîne qui est
excellent et bien le rapport
intermédiaire ou le premier rapport
inspecteurs dit bien que pour le moment
il n'y a aucune trace des fameuses armes
de destruction massive donc on peut tout
de même pas aller casser la tronche un
pays de 18 millions d'habitants dont une
bonne partie de ses 18 millions sont
exempts galaube de l'agonie une finale
on peut penser quand même que ce pays là
n'a pas grands moyens d'inquiéter la
plus grande puissance du monde alors
qu'on prenne des précautions bien sûr
qu'on aille voir sur place très bien
enfin bon
la guerre c'est pas vous croyez
sérieusement que les américains ils ont
envoyé 100 mille jihai géant servir à ça
ils ont fait tout ça pour les enlever
non ils n'ont sûrement pas fait tout ça
pour les enlever mais écoutez moi je
suis pas un pacifiste je suis un
pacifique
voilà alors tant qu'il n'y a pas de
preuve absolue que tout ça existe je
vois pas au nom de quoi on irait [ __ ]
sur la gueule de ce pays je n'ai pas une
passion pour le soleil moussanais
personnellement s'attaquera maintenant
sa peine et je le peuple irakien
franchement il m'a rien fait dans l'es11
il ya des gens tout à fait dignes de
respect là bas on peut pas leur taper
sur la tronche comme ça sur des
présomptions
voilà alors quand tu auras des preuves
peut-être qu'il faudra voir si l'on
trouve pas à ce moment là et de toute
façon
tout ça doit passer par si je me
souviens bien par le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu l'a dantec
les règles soient bien respectées non
s'il me semble me souvenir que c'est ça
la donner normalement un donc on va pas
faire ça sans sable enfin désormais
toute façon on a déjà la côte d'ivoire
la france elle est vraiment honnêtement
elle fait ce qu'elle peut pour que les
gens ne se s'entredéchirent pas non peut
pas on ne peut pas trouver que le
ministère étrangères dominique de
villepin a bien agi là dessus en tout
cas à écouter il est allé sur place et
il a essayé de temporiser les choses il
reste il a fait me semble t-il tout à
fait honnête rama est correctement son
travail il est alors sur l'intérieur de
la france sarkozy est ce que je savais
bien qu'il allait me la poser cette
petite question pourquoi mr bah écoute
et qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
trouve je me trouve je ne vous voulez
que je vous dise honnêtement le fond de
ma pensée oui je vais vous le dire
quitte à vous choquer la première des
choses à dire c'est que nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy a le sale boulot du
gouvernement c'est que comme tous les
ministres de l'intérieur il n'y a pas de
ministre de l'intérieur qui ait jamais
été populaire c'est le premier flic du
pays c'est pas marrant c'est difficile
particulièrement en ce moment
c'est vrai qu'il ya des menaces
terroristes un peu partout donc c'est
pas absolument génial c'est vrai qu'ils
s'attaquent un certain nombre de choses
avec lesquelles très honnêtement je vous
le dit personnellement je suis d'accord
un secteur je veux dire que le le
l'insécurité routière je suis totalement
épais mais fondamentalement ou une
voiture c'est pas une arme
voilà quand torres c'est très délicat
c'est à manipuler avec des pincettes
il ya des choses contre lesquelles il
faut lutter on parle d'une manière
générale de l'insécurité
moi je préfèrerais parler d insécurité
il ya une insécurité effectivement qui
est qui et qui existe qui existent
manière un peu plus aiguë aujourd'hui
parce que la société est probablement
plus dur il faut faire très attention
avec ce qu'on manipule kitty qui on
emmerde qui on emmerde pas à savoir que
très souvent mois pour l'avoir vu à
présent j'ai rencontré des ptic des
petits gars d'idées cité en question un
peu comme ça un peu machin comme ça et
puis on discutait trois minutes avec eux
et puis quand on peut prendre le temps
de discuter quand on quand ils
s'intéressent à vous vous intéressez à
eux vous apercevez que ce sont des
gosses comme tout le monde et que
simplement peut-être il faut il faut
peut-être faire qu'on leur rappelle ou
qu'on les aide à retourner à l'école où
il prendre un intérêt à cette école de
la république qui fera qu'à un moment
donné ils pourront devenir des hommes de
demain ceux qui ne peuvent pas toujours
faire dans le tas ya toujours des noyaux
de 2
dedans mes ardeurs ou de [ __ ] ou de
petits truands mais ils sont c'est une
poignée c'est rien c'est une tête
d'épinglé par rapport à la grande
majorité des gosses qu'on peut je ne
veux pas croire que ces gosses ça soit
perdue je ne veux pas le croire
voilà donc sarkozy trappe les mamans
personnellement je ne je ne peux pas en
dire du mal et lionel vous l'avez oublié
je n'ai pas changé de bord ma famille ma
sensibilité est toujours celle là je
n'ai pas oublié je ne je pense que c'est
lui qui pour le moment se fait oublier
sans doute parce qu'il en a besoin et
sans doute parce que je crois que quand
il a dit qu'il renonçait à la vie
politique je crois qu'il était sincère
c'est pas un effet de manche
c'est un type très droit à lionel jospin
regard venir non ah non on pensait par
non je pense pas non un bon nom très
bien est ce que vous avez pris les
bonnes résolutions pour 2003 pierre
aucune
ah bon vous êtes pas décidé d'arrêter de
fumer page puis j'arrête de décider si
je décide d'arrêter de fumer tous les
jours pour garçons et je mange des
pastilles et puis hein je m arrête un
changement et on est tous là alors le
nord-est et j'en suis au pastis jeu et
je filme dix fois moins qu'avant mais
enfin bon on entend m'arrêter comme vous
pouvez le constater je ne touche
non mais vous savez pourquoi vous avez
repris vous n'êtes pas voulu prendre un
patch si vous êtes cru très fort vous ai
dit je peux m'arrêter de fumée sans
pattes je les fais un an
essayez le pat je vais essayer le patch
qui érige vous mettez moi mais vous avez
d intérêt pour le patch il aurait quand
même pour vous pierre moi je comprends
bien non mais je sais que vous m'aimez
bien mais oui c'est beaucoup c'est vrai
alors la pièce donc s'appelle une leçon
de savoir vivre
c'est au théâtre du rond-point à 18h30
tous les soirs jusqu'au 18 janvier voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors donc le monologue s'appelle une
leçon de savoir vivre donc je vais vous
faire une interview une leçon de savoir
vivre
[Musique]
alors pierre arditi monsieur vraiment
vous savez vivre vous est ce qu est ce
qu il vaut mieux suivre une dame qui
monte un escalier pour éviter qu'elles
ne tombent évidemment en arrière où l'a
précédé pour pas regarder ses fesses
c'est lamentable c'est la mort vous
savez qu'il faut il faut la suivre
quitte à regarder ses fesses oui bah ça
veut dire qu'on sait qu'elle va tomber
alors ça veut dire que voilà oui enfin
c'est ça bon alors au cinéma oui vaut-il
mieux essayer d'ouvrir lentement un
bonbon ou bien y aller d'un coup sec
pour que ça fasse le moins de bruit
possible et bien au cinéma c'est très
simple il faut pas manger de bonbons
parce qu'on est pas au restaurant les
jours raconte l'histoire est l'anglais
un jour alain resnais t au cinéma est il
allé voir un film je pas lequel est
devant lui avec deux dames qui parlait
alors elle parle elle parle elle parlait
puis abandonné la lumière baisse
et puis la lumière s'éteint qu'il rideau
s'ouvre et puis le générique commence
elle continue elle continue à parler
alors à l'aréna qui est très poli ne dit
rien et puis un moment donné la première
image du film apparaît il ya deux
acteurs qui se regardent ils les bonnes
femmes continuent de parler alors un
moment donné très poliment il redit
mesdames et mesdames
est-ce que vous pouvez vous taire parce
que le film est commencée et à ce moment
là il ya une des deux âmes qui s'est
retournée équidés vers rennes et qui lui
et qui lui a dit mais monsieur ils ne
disent rien
[Applaudissements]
alors bien leçons de savoir-vivre
vaut-il mieux insulté un postier qui
vous fait attendre où une employée de la
sécu qui vous a oublié font insulter
personne franchement dans un bus
vaut-il mieux laisser sa place à une
jeune femme enceinte moche ou à une
vieille dame séduisante
écoutez comme n'y a qu'une seule place
il faut le céder à l'une des deux poings
dans la voie là peut-il mieux montrer sa
déception de ne pas avoir eu de molière
ou de ne pas avoir eu de césar faut
montrer aucune déception parce que je
suis bien placé pour en parler en ayant
eu quelques-uns les molières les césar
c'est absolument délicieux c'est comme
une bonne critique ça fait du bien comme
ça quand on se retourne sur son passé en
dix ans une certaine époque les gens de
mon métier mon reconnu mais d'une
certaine manière ils peuvent vous
reconnaître aussi sans césar et sans
mollir mode il mieux savoir mort et au
savoir vivre faut savoir vivre savoir
mourir ça sert à rien parce que ça à
temps tout le monde et on n'apprend pas
la mort la mort ça s'apprend pas ça peut
se douter ça peut se craindre ça peut
faire du mal
peu douloureux mais ça ne s'apprend pas
la vie par contre ça c'est absolument
fondamental le seul petit bruit de nous
qui restera ce sera la manière dont il
aura vécu
je pense à un truc leur temps en temps
que vous êtes là vous allez me faire par
exemple un beau c'est lamentable comme
ça je l'aurais en stock
serge tu allais 6-1 2-3 c'est lamentable
mais c'est lamentable
elle est bien esprit me faire un c'est
formidable non c'est remarquable ce sera
plus vous ça ces remarques faites moi
assez remarquable ça j'aurai les deux
c'est remarquable
merci vidéo sans beurre dans l'année
parce que vous n'avez pas venir non plus
toutes les semaines pour dire ses
remarques à bout c'est lamentable avec
moi je n'en suis demandé d'être nous
vous remercie ça vous évite de venir
pourrait faire autre chose voilà c'est
ça comme ça où je fais potiche même
quand je suis pas lassé merci très bien
et j'accueille maintenant florence
moncorgé gabin
[Musique]
vous fait séduisant ans clarence pierre
arditi très très à part lui je vois pas
qui peut être le double canon bon alors
meilleur vous connaissez pas ce que vous
allaitez script florence sur un film ou
jouer pierre arditi je crois que c'était
de guerre lasse avec nathalie baye
d'ailleurs et christophe malavoy et
alors page 68 de votre livre vous faites
broad compliments sur en souvenez pas
j'ai un péno j'ai pas vu le livre vous
allez voir ce qu'elle dit oui ghoul a
dit deux gars là se réunissent et sur le
même plateau nathalie baye pierre arditi
christophe malavoy et jean bouise et
cetera
robert était un bulldozer robert enrico
à un réalisateur seul arditi nager comme
un poisson dans l'eau
il est des acteurs qui n'ont besoin ni
d'encouragements ni d'indication qui ne
sont influençables ni par les colères et
les sautes d'humeur du metteur en scène
ni par les impondérables du tournage les
vieux routiers du métier c'est moins
sympa nous tu es invité les
personnalités taillé dans le roc
les natures dans le jeu et sur net car
et précis aussi à l'aise le premier jour
de tournage que le dernier geste fort
mais c'est quand même hein
métier gestion amoureuse venu - oui
allez vas toi tu vois ta toune boîte à
me le dire
bon dieu c'était renvoient à l'époque et
moi aussi
on a extrait on a un extrait du film
[Musique]
vous l'avez le le lamentable pas c'est
ce que vient de faire
lamentable mais c'est lamentable très
bien la série alors florence bonsoir
dont vous êtes la fille de jean gabin et
vous publié aux éditions du cherche midi
un livre qui s'appelle quitte à avoir un
père autant qu'ils s'appellent gaba
[Musique]
alors votre bouquin florence est pas une
bio de jean gabin il y en a eu il ya
celle de bruno l'un qui est très célèbre
c'est pas non plus une autobiographie de
votre part c'est plutôt des souvenirs en
fait c'est un livre que vous avez écrit
au départ pour pour votre mère pour
raconter un petit peu laissé une trace
de ce que vous aviez vécu ensemble avec
avec jean gabin ce que les biographies
non non pas raconter et malheureusement
vous avez rendu votre manuscrit au
cherche midi la veille de son décès donc
elle n'a jamais lu mais vous avez eu le
temps de lui en parler quand même oui en
fait en fait j'ai écrit ce livre parce
que je voulais qu'on s'amuse toutes les
deux ensemble à à lire ce livre après
parce qu'il y avait tellement de deux
d'anecdotes croustillantes sur mon père
des choses que les gens ne peuvent pas
imaginer et on en parlait tellement
ensemble que je me suis dit bon wagon
c'est vrai on va écrire ça et puis on va
tous s'amuser bon elle n'aura pas eu
mais enfin mon frère l'a lu les proches
de la famille ont lu et ils ont tous
bien bien ri ça a plu
ah oui c'est gratuit alors jean gabin et
et fils semble c'est pas très bien du
d'une chanteuse de café-concert et son
père était comédien d'opérette et il a
commencé gabin comme boy aux folies
bergères survie alors c'est comme ça
qu'il a épousé une dénommée gadby basse
et vous avez rencontré d'ailleurs un qui
venait dé foi chez vous vous aviez chez
elle commence à oui j'ai des vagues
souvenirs quand j'étais petit mais c'est
une femme charmante
ils s'étaient mariés il avait 18 ans il
y avait prescription la deuxième épouse
de votre père c'était dorian une
danseuse nue à l'époque des folies
bergères des décades arrêts ensuite il a
eu michel morgant marlene dietrich enfin
et ces femmes les plus belles du monde
ils sont tombés dans les bras et son
troisième mariage c'était votre maire
dominique fournier qui était mannequin
chez lanvin lors une anecdote
extraordinaire canon avant de se marier
avec votre père
elle n'était pas encore chez lanvin
était cher mais cela vu passer dans la
rue c'est ça non oui elle m'a elle m'a
raconté cette histoire très amusante
c'est à dire quel était l est et je
crois même vendeuse chez hermès en
connaît pas encore
mannequin et tout d'un coup il ya eu un
attroupement et tout lé tout le
personnel de chez hermès s'est précipité
devant sur les carreaux le nez collé aux
vitres il y avait une limousine qui
passait avec gabin et marlène dietrich
une décapotable et elle dit comme comme
toutes les midinettes je me suis
précipité pour voir gabin et marlène
passé sans penser qu'un an plus tard je
serai mariée avec la foule dans
l'histoire alors quand vous laissez
votre père est fou de joie parce qu'ils
croyaient qu'ils pouvaient pas avoir
d'enfant
en fait il m'a eu 3 vous évidemment
votre soeur valérie votre frère mathias
et à partir de là
gabin été saisi par une espèce d'anxiété
une espèce d'angoissé la responsabilité
familiale c'était peut-être quelque
chose qu'ils ne voulaient pas en tous
les cas c'était très lourd pour ses
épaules d'après ce qu'on lit dans votre
livre
mais je pense que c'était quelque chose
à laquelle ils n'étaient pas préparés
quand ils en avaient terriblement envie
mais il en avait très peur et
bon il a un enfant peut-être il aurait
pu assumer l'un d'eux poids mais vous
savez que ma mère aurait continué s'il
avait paraît il a dit stop on serait
peut-être six ou sept ans maintenant
ouais mais c'était une responsabilité
énorme pour lui il avait du mal à faire
face
oui c'est ça des enfances etc il était
comme devant des jouets donc nous tu ne
connais pas le mode d'emploi
c'est ça oui alors d'abord il envoie
votre mère en clinique
huit jours avant l'accouchement c'est
quand même beaucoup et cela à vous dites
cela ne faisait que commencer car
l'angoissé et l'anxiété serait l'essence
même de son caractère et elle est joué
un rôle déterminant dans son
comportement futur transformer le
séducteur décontracté en père de famille
responsable et on horrible misanthrope
c'est à dire qu'à partir de là
effectivement il se referme complètement
sur lui même et je me mets à la place de
de votre mère qui avait connu ce
séducteur flamboyant qui d'un seul coup
se retrouve avec un petit vieux la
maison quoi pas un petit vieux quand
même si vous dites comme tel s'il
souhaitait vieillir prématurément et la
souffrance de ma mère dit vous ton père
se fait plus vieux qu'il n'est
d'ailleurs souvent il s'est
recroquevillé sur lui-même
oui mais c'est terry vous épouser
quelqu'un de séducteur et un coup vous
vous retrouvez avec quelqu'un en
charentaises à la maison et c'est ça
vous voyez c'est pas mais c'est vrai que
à chaque enfant il a pris du ventre et
il est devenu un monsieur respectable et
je pense d'ailleurs que ça lui a permis
de faire sa seconde can oui parce que
s'il était resté avec bien sûr tente du
séducteur il est extraordinaire c'est
qu'en fait ils étaient dans la vie comme
nous on le voyait au cinéma d'une
certaine façon espèce de pépé bourgon
alors très angoissée d'abord il était
obsédé par l'idée que les enfants
aillent pas aux toilettes ça ça fait
bizarre mais oui parce que si vous
voulez j'étais normal moi j'ai des
enfants je m'en occuper tout bien
entendu je les aime et donc mais vous
vous regardez si vos toilettes non
important alors mais non enfin c'est pas
moi c'est parce que vous ne vous
intéressez pas assez vos enfants
sérieusement je vais essayer parce que
moi j'avais une grand mère qui ne
jugé qu'il ne nous jugez bien que si
nous allions au toit d'abord et en
fonction de ce que nous y avions fait
nous avions fait la petite commission on
était des gens moyens et c'est la grosse
commission étaient des gens très bavard
est alors très bien jean gabin mois jean
gab à 37,2 de température les enfants
n'est pas l'école par exemple 37 2 1 et
toi et puis alors il était très attentif
comme ça très très très méticuleux très
pointilleux même temps il faisait
rarement des câlins et des bisous jamais
j'ai vu mon père me prendre dans les
bras même le matin quand on arrivait
pour y prenez il était toujours à son
bureau le matin avec son café et ses
clubs parce qu'il avait toujours ses
clubs devant lui alors on lui faisait le
bisou mais c'est tout wang a bien dormi
pas comment ça va et ou alors prendre
par la taille moi je fais ça avec mise
enfin elle prend part la taille sont
leur dire bonjour et huit noms alors en
arriver on dit bonjour à la queue leu
leu pur parfois il était fini pour la
journée quand on le voit dans des films
avec des enfants par exemple il ya
quelques films tournés avec des
arrivants et on voit bien qu'il est
l'enfant est un être étrange et privés
même si il devient tendre dans le film
avec l'enfant itunes et tendresse
toujours un peu comme ça un peu viril un
peu alors disons le machin et ira faire
ça tire ça puis m'emmerde pas bon rester
comme ça peut-être qu'après tout ça
n'était que le reflet comme beaucoup
beaucoup d'acteurs on va tirer dans nos
vies ce qu'on ramène sur l'écran et donc
dans sa vie depuis il y avait une
certaine timidité visage nous je suppose
que c'est une timidité
parce qu'il nous aurait pris nous aurait
nourri nous aurait dit quoi il fallait
tout vinet c'est sûr qu'il y avait de
l'amour mais il fallait deviner
alors bon il y avait ça qu'à l'arrivée
des manies incroyable c'est à dire que
par exemple quand il écrasé une
cigarette
si vous écrasez pendant une plante comme
ça pour être sûr qu'ils étaient bien les
tatous ou le gaz si le gaz était bien
éteint il se relever la nuit ça c'est de
voir gabarits comme le mec quoi l'homme
1 du cinéma français voit quand même à
c'était le chef chef du clan et alors il
se relever la nuit
c'est terrible parce qu'ils devraient
terriblement malheureux
avec cette anxiété c'est horrible alors
quand on essaye de comprendre d'où ça
vient il ya effectivement le fait qu'il
avait vécu deux guerres déjà donc la
première évidemment c'était très dur
pour lui la deuxième où il s'était
comporté d'une façon extrêmement
héroïque et brillante évidemment et
ensuite il y avait eu cette traversée du
désert après la guerre parce qu'il avait
refusé de faire les portes de la nuit de
prévert écart mais ces montants qui est
fait des portes de la nuit il disait
c'est une belle connerie d'heure lui
n'était pas à wil a dit ladd et il a dit
c'est une belle connerie mais à l'époque
il devait le faire avec marlene dietrich
ouais et il s'est séparé et s'est séparé
d'elle 1 donc bon bah le film s'est pas
fait du tout avec eux ensuite aussi ce
qui peut expliquer son angoisse et ses
problème c'est qu'après la guerre il
avait eu cette traversée du désert 10
ans et éclipse et sa carrière n'a
redémarré qu'en 53 avec touchez pas au
grisbi donc quand même passé pas mal
d'années comme ça sur le ca vous est
arrivé vous ça non non jamais enfin il
faut pas oublier quand même que gabin a
fait la guerre comme un sapin un acteur
mais pas un grand nombre d'acteurs un
lapin il ya jean pierre aumont il ya
quelques autres mais sont ils sont
vraiment comporté envers ou alors ils
ont ils ont jamais ramené parce que
c'était des gens simples et qu'il
ramenait pas mais enfin gabin s'est
comporté comme un héros par les remet en
termes clairs
alors il était il était très inquiet sur
l'avenir aussi c'est à dire que par
exemple il considérait que le cinéma
c'est une profession provisoire un
métier de maboule comme vous le racontez
et il avait confiance dans la terre
c'était vraiment comme ça ils disaient
légaux seront à bouffer s'il pensait pas
que le cinéma allait lui permettre
d'élever ses enfants très longtemps et
oui parce que comme il avait eu cette
traversée du désert il s'est dit un jour
ou l'autre on va pu me demander
bon ça y est je crois que c'est inhérent
à tous comédiens sont presque tous les
comédiens ont toujours peur que le
téléphone ne sonne plus bon là il avait
pratiquement plus sonner pendant
une dizaine d'années donc il s'est dit
je vais acheter de la terre et puis
comme j'aime la terre et bien au moins
les enfants ont toujours de quoi manger
il y aura toujours des poireaux à
cueillir des pommes de terre il a acheté
une propriété en 53 des dès la fin de la
période noire il a commencé avec
quelques lapins annan et en 76 il avait
quand même 300 têtes de bétail et 15 15%
quoi donc c'est quand même
il y avait les deux mains y avait des
demi sang il y aurait pu ressembler à ça
faisait pas mal que là aussi ça a été
pour lui une source d'angoissé parce
qu'il ya des problèmes avec les
agriculteurs
avec l'effet naisseur en 76 continue la
sécheresse par exemple la fnsea dit pas
de pognon pour gabin pourquoi pas parce
qu'il ya de l'argent il a besoin il
revint de il n'a pas besoin d'elle alors
là il a mis le le domaine en vente un
carrément creed oui tout de suite avait
tout de suite il a pris le téléphone il
a mis le domaine en vente
ça ça lui avait asséné un sacré coup il
est mort quelques mois après et il est
mort quelques temps après cela ah non
mais c'est la vaisselle avait achevé sa
parce qu'il a toujours essayé de rentrer
dans ce monde paysan et le monde paysan
n'a jamais voulu de l'accueillir
ça a été c'est vrai que cette année
serait vraiment son truc en plus à lui
ça mais c'était son truc ferait rentrer
dans le monde présente dans le monde du
cinéma
il aimait bien bâtir faire des choses
alors au cinéma par exemple ils avaient
peur de demander des trop gros cachet
est ce que c'est par peur de plus bosser
ou c'est par une espèce de morale
d'honnêteté comme ça plutôt par morales
ouais parce que bon c'est quelqu'un qui
avait travaillé à l'usiné quand il était
jeune quand même il avait 14 15 ans et
il a eu des moments très difficiles il
était d'une famille quand même très
pauvres et à partir du moment où il a
commencé à bien gagner sa vie
au tout début il a trouvé que c'était
bien qu'il n'avait pas besoin de plus
et puis pour plus les cachets augmenté
il est arrivé à un certain plafond
et après il s'est dit bon bain j'arrête
parce que effectivement il ya des gars
dans le métier qui ont moins de chance
que moi et puis par pudeur je n'ai pas
envie de demander trop d'argent c'est ça
les gens comme ça c'est incroyable il se
retrouver dans un film il y avait un
acteur qui était au même niveau que lui
par exemple au box office
le type gagner plus mais ça a enfin sa
ronde est évidemment hystérique votre
mère est ce qu'on comprend évidemment
maintenant qu'il a eu son agent
ça c'est bien ça s'est très bien passé
et puis après il a après ça a été fini
il s'est débrouillé tout seul et ce
n'est pas un homme d'affaires mon père
et votre mère alors vous en parlait pas
beaucoup dans le livre florence ça doit
être terrible pour réaction qu'on a on
l'a vu quoi elle épouse le fringant jean
gaba se retrouve avec un petit plus en
plus papy l'argent bas ils n'en
demandent pas tellement ils dépensent
beaucoup d'argent dans ses propriétés
que ça a coûté des fortunes vous
racontez vous raconter tout ça votre
mère est-ce qu'elle avait envie de
partir des fois elle est partie une fois
à huy est là elle a pris son petit sac
son petit bagage et les parties pendant
trois quatre jours et après les revenus
puis l'huile a rigolé il a dit bahout
était allié au bas je suis parti à
l'hôtel puis il ya des moments où
c'était pas c'était pas évident ouais
mais je parle peu de ma mère dans sa
passion c'est pas ben oui parce que ma
mère était vivant et j'avais pas
suffisamment de recul
mon père j'ai du recul il ya quand même
très très longtemps un et ma mère était
là donc c'est très difficile de parler
de quelqu'un qui est là qui est vivant
il faut quand même est certain qu est ce
qu est ce que vous pensez qu'elle a
regretté d'avoir épousé votre père ah
non jamais jamais jamais malgrès que ce
soit quelqu'un de dans merde en deux
avec des défauts épouvantable non non
non
ah non quand elle quand il est parti
elle est restée 27 ans tout seul ah oui
non ça a été un manque terrible terrible
terrible alors gabin le bonheur d'une
certaine façon lui apparaissait
anormalement je suis un peu comme ça
mais ça m'a aidé non mais ça m'a aidé
parce que je me dis non maintenant je me
dis depuis je les lui ne fait pas ton
jean gabin parce que non ça serve oui ça
sert finalement le bonheur lui apparaît
c'est anormal c'est à dire par exemple
le matin dans la maison tout le monde
attendait le problème tout le monde
héééé madame gabin à votre mère disais
mais qu'est ce qui va encore pouvoir
inventer aujourd'hui pour nous gâcher la
journée quoi donc tout le monde
l'attendait qui seul avis lever
effectivement il trouvait jusqu'au soir
1 oui oui y avait toujours quelque chose
les jours il n'y avait rien on est
inquiet on faisait peut-être que ça va
arriver un peu plus tard
et puis on se couchait n'y avait pas eu
ouais mais le lendemain avec lendemain
mais oui pour gâcher la journée
il faut que je me suis un peu comme ça
alors vous n'empêche que bon malgré tout
vous êtes heurté à lui ce qui est normal
quand une jeune fille on se heurte à son
père j'imagine que c'est courant mais
c'est aller un peu plus loin c'est à
dire qu'au moment de votre adolescence
vous avez était dépressive
vous avez eu ce que vous appelez dans le
bouquin un trou noir enfants tous les
cas faisait penser au suicide
c'était sa personnalité qui vous emmener
jusque là moi j'avais été élevé dans un
cocon aseptisé et je trouvais que en
fait la vie probablement devait être
autre chose est assez poke là j'ai
commencé à lire énormément j'ai commencé
à découvrir beaucoup de choses des
auteurs des philosophes tout ça et je me
disais mais ça n'a strictement rien à
voir avec la vie qu'on a un prix et lui
évidemment qui ne lisaient pas donc j'ai
essayé de parler avec lui de ces choses
là
on sait évidemment un plus de chf ou tel
autre et puis ça a été de mal en pis et
puis moi j'ai c'est vrai qu'à un moment
je me suis dit mais qu'est-ce que je
fais là
pourquoi est-ce que je suis là enfin
vous - tout un tas de questions je
serais incapable de vous dire pourquoi
mais ça a été quand même très très loin
mais je pense pas qu'il en était lui
même responsable c'est moi qui l'a dit
comment quand il vous a vu dans cet état
avec quand l'état était critique
on m'a quand même emmené chez le médecin
ouais bah oui parce que là c'était quand
même devenu j'avais quand même maigri de
15 kilos en un mois un lay avait du
souci à se faire quand même été assez
dur avec vous parce que par exemple le
cheval qui nous a promis pour le bepc
vous l'avez pas la voiture vous ne
l'avez pas dire que c'est terrible je
trouve de promettre quelque chose à un
enfant et pas lui offrir une cécité rit
parce que l'enfant il y croit lui donc
c'est assez émouvant bien qu'on vous
raconter ça pourquoi il faisait ça et je
pense qu'ils étaient il était très très
très maladroit et il disait une chose un
jour le lendemain c'était autre chose il
se rétractait il était très très très
difficile a scindé quand même et comme
en plus il a été très dur dans son
éducation qu'il fallait qu'on se
débrouille seul puisqu'on n'a jamais eu
d'argent de poche moi j'ai travaillé
comme vendeuse pour pouvoir de l'argent
de poche et je lui rendais la monnaie au
centime près j'allais acheter le pari
turf et il fallait que j'en mets au
centime frais il ne voulait pas que je
garde un centime donc j'étais habitué à
ça un effectivement main le jour où il
m'a dit bah tu auras pas la voiture j'ai
été déçu si je me suis dit ça fait
partie du personnage mais le cheval j'ai
quand même ça fait mal parce que ce
cheval je l'attends d'être plus loin
pourquoi ce que c'était une punition
obsolète est pas une puisque ils avaient
peur qu'un accident oui j'y disais que
mais je pense que ça devait aussi
l'emmerdé qui est un cheval comme ça
improductif à la maison tout ce qui
n'était pas productif déployés ici pas
tennis pas eu d'avis de mentalité on
avait on n'avait pas de décoration à la
maison tous les murs et aigri faut dire
que vous déménagiez tellement souvent
que le temps de bécaud et il n'y avait
même pas quelqu'un les placards on
rentrait dans la cuisine maman disait
mon mais la vaisselle il avait oublié
des placards 1 donc il n'y avait rien il
y avait tout ce qui n'était tout ce qui
n'était pas de rapport était totalement
prohibés de la maison ah oui oui alors
évidemment on vous raconter sa vie vous
raconter aussi votre aventure
professionnelle à vous c'est à dire vous
traversez quand même le cinéma français
des années 70 et 80 vous participé à
beaucoup de beaucoup de grands films
notamment de guerre lasse avec notre ami
pierre arditi et puis un jour cgt sur
moi aussi j'étais sûr évidemment pas à
la elle a craqué un avant vous vous
croyez bien c'est lamentable mais c'est
lamentable
merci oui donc voila quoi un jour vous
craquez bah oui c'est normal il est beau
oui et puis surtout très tendre moi qui
avais manqué de tendresse s'est surtout
dite s'avère vous dites de long c'est
l'homme qui a été le plus tant le temps
avec moi toute ma vie de toute ma vie
oui mais c'est surtout ça parce que bon
beau beau sinon de très bon niveau mais
bien sûr qu'il est je veux dire n'y a
pas que ça parce que s'il y avait eu que
la beauté heureusement qu'ils aient pas
que ça à la première fois que vous le
voyez ça aussi c'est extraordinaire
c'est comme votre mère quand elle est
chère mais c'est qu'elle voit votre
perdra décapotable rue du faubourg
saint-honoré avec marlene dietrich von
journée sur un plateau comme ça tout
petit et vous voyez de long et quelques
années après à pontarlier
voilà voilà dès 13 ans à 23 ans
voilà en dix ans il a fallu dix ans
voilà dix ans voilà si ça s'appelle
quitte à avoir un père autant qu'ils
s'appellent gabardane messieurs
c'était assez
alors le père il avait une expression
s'était toujours dit don aux gamines
alors je vous faire une interview didon
gamine mais c'est pas moi qui vais vous
poser des questions dit loulou tout ce
beau monde la moitié du carnet bon laval
l'autre moitié est moyenne ils ont 8 et
je vous dis virton pays bas bien sûr oui
je suis fier de mon père bah oui quand
même c'est un grand bonhomme a jamais
non ah non non je n'ai jamais recherché
mon père dans les hommes que j'ai connu
pas du tout ah non je n'aurais pas du
tout voulu vivre avec
ni physiquement ni ailleurs ni ni
moralement
ah non pas du tout mais je trouve que
c'est un grand bonhomme et je lui jeune
que moi c'était de devenir mécanicien de
locomotive
oui ça je le savais ça je le savais oui
parce qu'il voyait passer les trains à
l'arrêt de sa chambre quand il était
petit voilà c'est extraordinaire qu en
fait la seule chose qui l'intéressé
vraiment c'était les chevaux et les
trains les acteurs français
la sncf a peut-être perdu mais cinéma ya
gagné tout à fait on est d'accord
ils ont bien mis j'ai le monde et je
tiens toujours lochies projet toujours
on va michel toujours toulouges icône
elle n'a jamais dit qu'elle était colle
à la peau c'est pas ça
bien aller
il a dit c'est la poubelle razès que
j'ai jamais vu comme elle est au mois
deux à penser la même chose
dix longues il est le petit de long
équipé d'un petit peu de tout le temps à
ça ça je ne dirais pas bon ça ça reste
ma vie privée ça dans un prochain livre
a dit dong gaming est ce que c'est vrai
que j'étais chien très chiant
tu aurais préféré de la ville ils ont dû
re ah j'aurais bien aimé être la fille
de lignes rouges ah oui c'était
quelqu'un de très très très loin
et encore vous êtes marié la première
fois contre l'avis de votre père
lino est venu au mariage oui et c'est
drôle parce que
effectivement maintenant que j'ai plus
mes parents quand j'ai un problème c'est
pas mon père que je pense je me dis
pourquoi est-ce que lino n'est pas là
parce que c'est lui qui met des très
très drôle plus que mon père ly dongming
la peur de me ressembler on lui jean au
je pense que j'ai été défaut est que
plus ça va aller plus je vais te
ressembler dis moi tu aimerais me dire à
quoi qui ont été là tous les lieux sont
riches en oméga bouche à oreille ben je
te remercie de m'avoir donné ta force
mais malheureusement tu m'as donné la
fragilité
gigaba picard
autant
on
je suis
et j'ai dit j'ai lu ça
juste à côté
ça m'en sors
voir
d merci
prêté au jeu merci beaucoup donc didier
en ce moment vous avez un dvd une vhs de
votre spectacle qui s'appelle en
attendant gustin oui et puis vous êtes
aussi en tournée j'imagine os continue
spectacle qu'on la joue et un an avant
oui plus d'un an à paris et puis
maintenant ça fait plus d'un an que j'y
retourne avec ce spectacle et je suis
ravi parce que c'est une super
expérience pour revenir à ce qu'on vient
de faire c'était pour moi très émouvant
de faire la voix de jean gabin à sa
fille voilà merci merci merci didier
vivez l'usta en attendant du starman
messieurs
[Musique]
voilà didier gustin merci
blind test n'a qu'une valeur spéciale de
l'aventuré ce soir
et maintenant et maintenant
ainsi l'homme qui protège et françois
mitterrand voici daniel brands bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
bonsoir les combats bonsoir florence
moncorgé gabin pierre arditi voilà alors
je dis gorille en fait pas du tout vous
étiez interlocuteur privilégié de
françois mitterrand alors
l'interlocuteur privilégié
c'est parmi les membres de la garde
rapprochée de françois mitterrand ce
qu'on a choisi pour être ses
interlocuteurs pour simplifier le
travail parce qu'il peut pas s'adresser
à tout le monde tout le temps c'est ça
exactement pour faire la liaison entre
lui et puis les services de sécurité qui
étaient autour de lui chargé de sa
protection
voilà alors interlocuteur privilégié
c'est le titre d'un livre que vous
publiez chez jean claude lattès
[Musique]
alors en fait au départ vous étiez
membre du gign et puis vous avez
participé à la création de la gsp r le
groupe de sécurité de la présidence de
la république avec combien d'hommes dans
ce groupe où les dernières années on
était 107 500 personnes rien que pour
défendre mitterrand pour défendre les
gagnants ils se regardent ça comprenez
toute la logistique qui allait avec les
gens pour entretenir les voitures des
gens pour faire tout ce qui est
administratif est forcément ceux qui
étaient sur le terrain qu'ils avaient un
rôle plus opérationnels ne s'occupait
pas de tout ça ouais donc 107 ça
regroupe l'ensemble du personnel alors
interlocuteur privilégié évidemment on
devient rapidement un intime du
président parce qu'on est en est liée à
tout ce qui passe bien entendu alors
avant tout il ya sa protection
et là vous raconter l'équipe et de
sarajevo en 1992 quand mitterrand va
là-bas et au moment où les liquoreux
d'école sous les tirs
vous voulez l'enroulé dans une
couverture anti grenade en kevlar et là
ils refusent ils refusent ils vous
proposent de la m vous en disant vous
avez plus besoin que moi vous êtes
jeunes moi j'ai déjà fait ma vie et c
est ce que c'était de la frime
parce qu'il y avait des journalistes
autour de vous ou est ce qu'il avait
vraiment pas peur de mourir
non je pense que c'était pas de la frime
ça pouvait pas l'être parce que les
journalistes effectivement il y en avait
au moment où il me dit tout ça ils sont
assez loin donc ils peuvent pas le temps
de ne pas le voir
donc je pense que c'était c'était
sincère et courageux alain je crois oui
j'en suis même sûr alors quand vous
voyez le président chirac qui se fait
tirer dessus 14 juillet qu'envoyer
bertrand delanoë qui prend un coup de
couteau lors de ces nuits blanches
ça vous fait quoi vous pensez qu'ils
sont mal protégés ces gens là je pense
pas qu'ils sont mal protégés en tout cas
pas le président la république actuel
parce qu'ils bénéficient des mêmes
services que le président mitterrand et
pour certains des mêmes hommes donc mais
il ya peut-être eu quelques lacunes au
niveau
de l'accès à la tribune dans laquelle
s'est trouvée le tireur est à bertrand
delanoë
bon je sais pas du tout comment il est
protégé mais bon la protection c'est une
volonté avant tout de la personne qui
est protégé qu'il faut l'accepter et
puis collaboré avec elle sinon les
choses sont difficiles vrai que c'est
une attitude un petit peu démagogique
d'une certaine façon de dire moi je suis
prêt du peuple j'ai on a besoin d'être
protégée moi je pense oui oui d'ailleurs
le président mitterrand a eu beaucoup de
mal à se faire à nous quand on est
arrivé et puis petit à petit il a vu
l'utilité et puis je pense que les
derniers temps il pouvait plus se passer
de votre présence ouais alors il ya la
sécurité bien sûr et puis il ya tout le
reste
évidemment c'est à dire que vous passez
en revue dans votre livre daniel grand
ba ba toutes les affaires qui ont
émaillé les 14 ans de règne on pourrait
dire de françois mitterrand alors
d'abord il ya des irlandais de vincennes
alors là on a mis des preuves chez ces
irlandais dans leur appartement
donc ça a provoqué la démission du
capitaine barril et la dissolution de la
cellule antiterroriste vous parlez du
rainbow warrior alors là on apprend un
truc incroyable c'est que le rainbow
warrior tout le monde connaît c'est ce
ce bateau de greenpeace qui a été
dynamitée par les par les services
français charles hernu lui voulait faire
sauter le bateau en pleine mer
c'est à dire que survivre une certaine
façon la première idée qui émane est
plutôt desservi ce qui devait être
chargée de la réalisation de l'opération
était effectivement de faire disparaître
le bateau en pleine mer
et justement pour éviter des pertes
humaines inutiles la présidence et est
intervenu pour justement atténuer
différence est que ce qu'on le fasse
sauter quand même mais dans un port et
malheureusement moyens journalistes qui
au dernier moment après la première
explosion est remonté à voir pour
récupérer un appareil photo qui l'avait
laissé et qui
qui a été journaliste deuxième exposé
absolument alors vous parlez aussi des
morts dans l'entourage proche de
françois mitterrand
le suicide de françois de grossouvre qui
a eu lieu dans un bureau de l'elysée a
pas très loin de celui du président vous
vous dites y'a pas de doute c'est
vraiment un suicide à vous vous êtes
assez arrêté pour moi il ya aucun doute
ça ne peut être que celui-ci devrait
freiner quand même un petit peu des
problèmes parce qu'à un moment tout le
monde voulait prendre le corps de
françois de grossouvre et de l'emmener
quai branly où il avait un appartement
d'ailleurs et ses trous tour un caddie
faut pas y toucher pour sa protégée
c'est le poteau qui est intervenu
justement pour pas parce que c'était
certainement la dernière des choses à
faire est ce que ça aurait agressé
aggravé et soupçons oui oui si le mec se
suicide à l'elysée et qu'on retrouve son
corps quai branly fondations spéciales
jean un moment fatras les spécialistes
se serait rendu compte que le corps
avait été bougé de là alors il ya le
suicide de bérégovoy bout dit y'a pas de
problème sur le suicide de bérégovoy
non le fait qu'on laisse un homme
déprimé seul dans une voiture avec un
flingue dans la boîte à gants que le
garde du corps sont à y faire un petit
tour
tout ça c'est normal c'est normal parce
qu'apparemment c'est monsieur bérégovoy
qui avait demandé à son garde du corps
de le laisser tranquille donc il pouvait
aussi arriver aux personnes qui étaient
protégés d'avoir un petit peu d'air et
de vouloir se retrouver tout seul et que
l'armée était est laissé dans la boîte à
gants de la voiture effectivement c'est
un petit peu c'est à mon avis c'est une
facette une erreur de la part de la
personne qui a assuré sa sécurité parce
qu'on se sépare jamais de sa norme
on a monté cette histoire d'une manière
qui devenait scandaleuse et je pense que
cet homme qui était un homme qui avait
le sens de l'honneur à papus porter ce
déshonneur qui arrivait sur lui on peut
imaginer qui n'est pas supporter ça et
qu'il ait décidé de cesser de vivre
moi en tout cas oui c'est l'explication
la plus plausible je pense en tout cas
qu'à l'époque
peu importe on a fait tout un foin sur
le fait qu'il avait emprunté un million
mais franc sais plus quel âge
après 50 ans un plan de cinq ans de bons
et loyaux services 1 bat d'abord à la
sncf ensuite mon dieu seigneur il n'a
pas emprunté cet argent là et il n'a pas
fait par pot de vin par choses comme ça
il a simplement emprunté un peu de
l'argent pour ça quand même là
effectivement grossouvre bérégovoy bon
d'accord il ya peu là quand même assez
quand même
roger patrice pelât la sphère la plus
bizarre a invité son ami il était il
était l'ami personnel du chef de l'état
enfin vous dites quand même s'il y avait
un intérêt à éliminer quelqu'un saurait
pu être peu là parce que le délit
d'initié dans lequel était impliqué
mettez en cause beaucoup de monde quand
même un so lu ment sa mort elle pourrait
dire est arrivé forte à propos des
tarifs est forte à propos mais on ne
peut pas imaginer une seule seconde que
françois mitterrand le connaissant et
sachant dans la fidélité qui était la
sienne à vis à vis de ses amis oui tu
sais plus je suis sûr qu'il aurait
préféré tombé les armes à la main plutôt
que de sacrifier son ami comme ça
monsieur
pour moi sa famille qu'il était fidèle à
busqué donc c'est vrai que l'ayant était
à bout ce qui pourrait n'être absolue la
réflectivité une autre époque que j'ai
pas connue avec eux alors là c'est à
mazarine là dessus car on me dit pas
voulait pas connu danielle bousquet il
venait dîner rugby hier à me
personnellement j'ai jamais vu hier mais
bon j'étais pas là tous les jours donc
alors il yal'affaire mazarine alors là
on rentre dans la vie privée de françois
mitterrand les femmes tiennent une
grande place vous dites dans la vie de
mitterrand vraiment des qui voyez une
gonzesse c'était comme un fou il était
alors on va absolument y était il était
particulièrement sensible à la gente
féminine le bon
moi je parle y en ad'autres je le seul
il y avait ses limites la limite on peut
supposer
moi je trouve ça soit voilà exactement
et vous je préfère savoir la personne
qui est en charge des destinées de mon
pays je préfère le savoir sensible à ce
genre de choses aux plaisirs de la vie
en tout cas plutôt que le contraire
ouais et puis bon avec ce qui se passe
en ce moment on pourrait même peut-être
se dire que certains feraient bien de
s'en inspirer plus d'essayer ce que vous
êtes en train de lire là c'est qu'il
faudrait mieux que george bush se fasse
tailler des pipes par monica lewinsky
alors
bien alors donc je vais gamme le roi de
la vie à la nocturne ce françois
mitterrand là et vous vous étiez là
obligé de surveiller au début surtout
après l'âge et la maladie faisant elle
est sans doute de plus en plus de
difficultés il devait venir l'elysée
après après certains jusqu'à la fin et
des gonzesses qui sont venus à l'elysée
absolument oui
alors bon il ya les pouces vj team
évidemment danielle mitterrand qui était
rue de bièvre la mère de mazarine
pingeot qui était rue jacob tout ça a
été bien bien organisés et puis les
autres
alors effectivement il ya cette très
belle fille brune à de moindres honorant
germain qui habitait boulevard saint
germain
c'est qui honnêtement je sais pas qui
c'est non je vous assure je vous assure
que l'on met la plupart de toute façon
on s'intéressait pas ce genre de
problèmes c'est le service vous le dire
est pas vraiment c'est clair un nom mais
honnêtement je ne sais pas le jeune
actrice elle avait moins de 30 ans elle
était très jeune oui très très jeune et
elle venait aussi à l'elysée allait
venus quelquefois l'elysée mais encore
une fois moi quand je vous parle de
femmes dans l'entourage du président
mitterrand je peux pas vous affirmer
qu'elles ont toutes été ses maîtresses
oui parce que forcément mon rôle à un
moment s'arrêter et la porte se fermait
pas ce qui se passe et n'avait donc plus
qu est-ce qu on peut supposer ce qu'on
veut parce que bon mais bon là nous on a
des images quand même
donc sélection c'est consternant
vraiment à ça tu peux me le faire ça
allons-y
vas-y alors serge tu lui fais un bon 4
comme ça allez vas-y c'est consternant
sans les ans
donc oui il a reçu des femmes à l'elysée
jusqu'au bout jusqu'à ce qu'il soit très
amoindris par là par la maladie françois
mitterrand est alors tout ça était très
compartimentée parce que par exemple on
apprend en lisant votre livre que les
seuls qui pouvaient partir en vacances
avec anne pingeot mazarine et françois
mitterrand c'était robert elisabeth
badinter wii tels que les autres
n'avaient pas le droit les jack lang les
relents du mal et je pense que sa vie
était assez effectivement et cloisonnée
donc ils avaient les gens qui voyaient
avec sa famille officiels et les gens
qui voyaient avec son amie avec laquelle
il vivait en fait alors concernant
mazarine mitterrand voulait voulait
toujours savoir où elle était c'est vrai
que pour un père curieux c'est le rêve
d'avoir des gens comme comme daniel
parce que vous étiez obligés de lui
rendre compte sans arrêt de ses faits et
gestes d'ailleurs elle elle se révolte
et des fois contre sa non au depor quand
elle était quand elle était une enfant
bruce a pas trop poser de problème mais
quand elle est arrivée dans
l'adolescence et l'accueil qu'elle a
commencé à devenir une femme
1 fectivement l'apprécier peut-être un
peu moins d'avoir des gens tout le temps
derrière elle a les pieds puis
éventuellement renseigner son père donc
dû être très difficile pour elle à
supporter il ya un truc terry c'est
qu'un jour vous êtes obligés d'aller
dire à françois mitterrand bas votre
fille elle n'a pas dormi chez sa mère
quoi oui ça faisait partie c'était aussi
notre or donc ne pas voir ça du côté le
petit rapporteur qui qui répètent tous
fait leur boulot pour nous c'était notre
boulot et puis surtout ça pouvait
constituer un problème au niveau de la
sécurité
parce que quelqu'un qui approchait
mazarine forcément rentrer dans le
cercle le plus intime et le plus secret
du président a donc pouvait l'atteindre
lui donc nous on était obligé de prendre
des précautions pas encore à ça et le
petit ami vous avez fait une enquête sur
lui un oui et vous avez découvert qu'il
quitterait le fréquentable absolue grand
salle et on n'a rien découvert d'anormal
trois sont donnés renseignement
donc on avait recueilli au président et
qui après lui jugé parce que la décision
ne lui appartenait pas évidemment alors
tout ça bon c'est vrai que c'est assez
amusant c voilà quoi c'est la france
s'est fait dos et le vaudeville c'est
tout ça bon l'homme s'est un peu moins
amusant c'est l'acharnement contre jean
edern hallier donc il voulait sortir un
livre sur la double vie de de françois
mitterrand l'honneur perdu de françois
mitterrand alors là quand même on voit
bien comment fonctionne la machine
politique c'est à dire que d'abord enfin
je dis pas vous mais je dis service
appelle tous les éditeurs en dix ans ce
serait une erreur de publier ce bouquin
1 et les éditeurs se couche tous c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait en l'occurrence pour
jean edern hallier oui au-delà de ça
vous vous attaquer directement alors
quand je dis vous c'est pas vous hein
ccc le groupe attaqué directement à jean
edern qui est déjà un peu paranoïaque
parce qu'il faut dire que j'en ai bien
de quoi connaître bien connu ils
s'envoyaient tellement de cocaïne et de
votre cas que ça rend paranoïaque de
toute façon donc vous vous aviez qu'à
pousser un petit peu le personnage dans
ses mauvais penchants je dirais il salsa
le poussait à bout et et des fois comme
ça il rencontré dans la journée
quelqu'un alors qui lui disait alors tu
es toujours prêt à sortir ton torchant
ou ou des choses comme ça donc
effectivement à l'autre devenez fou
parce que quand vous rencontrez trois
fois de suite la même personne dans la
journée dans des endroits différents et
que cette personne vous dit trois fois
de suite la la même chose au bout d'un
moment ça rend dingue non
absolument mais connaissant le
personnage c'était le but recherché de
toute façon parce que notre action
devait être limité dans le temps et puis
elle devait être de toute façon
restreinte parce qu'on pouvait pas faire
n'importe quoi on pouvait passer
impliqués et puis c'était pas notre
boulot
donc nous le but ça a été dans un
premier temps après avoir recueilli
certains renseignements sur lui à part
établi son profil psychologique
d'essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils
génèrent lui même ses propres angoisses
et puis éventuellement ça aurait servi à
le discréditer si ça avait été
nécessaire mais c'est vrai que vous
l'avez mis dans un état épouvantable
parce qu'à l'époque il se trouve que moi
je fréquentais un petit peu de gens
avaient rallié au tour de l'idiot
international et qu' il m'a raconté très
souvent que à l'imprimerie les documents
d'impression de l'idiot puisque nous ne
pouvons pas faire de livrer voulait
sortir son bouquin dans l'idiot
international journal et les documents
d'impression et ai été fracassée par
jour il faut voir là parce que ce qui a
été fait et tout ce qui a été fait n'est
pas uniquement de notre ressort donc moi
je vous répète en ce qui concerne la
sécurité juin dernier au départ
représenter un problème de sécurité donc
ça nous concerne et ça a été le début de
l' enquête après tout la faire il ya
plusieurs services qui sont intervenus
parce qu'évidemment nous n'avions pas
les moyens ni les compétences pour faire
tout ce qui a été fait ou apparemment
été fait parce que bon certaines choses
ont été établis depuis
alors évidemment le président devait
être au courant de ce qui se passait il
était peut-être pas au courant de la
méthode qui étaient envoyés ou du détail
de la méthode
mais bon c'est quand même lui qui qui
avait décidé la femme parce qu'il faut
dire là dessus c'est effrayant je trouve
moi toute façon ce qu'on entend là et
c'était c'est effrayant mais bon c'est
des choses semaine à imaginer que que
françois mitterrand ait pu être au
courant de ce type de méthode
donc on peut comprendre qu'après tour
les emplois genre la belgique c'est mémé
c'est moi ça me faisait pas que ça me
fait pas bander le moment où françois
mitterrand a dit au service je veux pas
que ce bouquin sorte puisque c'est lui
qui a décidé de parler de mazarine c'est
le restaurant le divellec c'est bien
après donc avoir du mont houy dit je
veux pas que ce bouquin sorte vous après
enfin vous et les autres vous être
obligé de faire ce qu'il faut pour ça
qu'ils sortent voilà oui quitte à le
harceler
oui méchamment mais c'est à vous qu'il
dit je ne veux pas que mon nom c'est pas
à nous qu'il dit au dessin est ce que
vous croyez jean-edern hallier quand il
est mort en faisant une chute de vélo à
deauville est ce que vous croyez que
c'est une mort naturelle au bruit oui
pour moi c'est une mort naturelle ouais
bien sûr on peut pas penser que c'est
une vengeance
à plus long terme non je peux je ne peux
pas imaginer une seule seconde unique le
président mitterrand quelle qu'elle soit
était quelqu'un était sa façon de voir
où sa façon de diriger les choses dans
certaines affaires ait pu arriver à
cette extrémité je le connaissais je
sais qu'il avait une grande un grand
respect de la personne humaine
et si alors que vous le pourchasse y est
que vous le art ce lié jean-edern
hallier s'était suicidé comme bérégovoy
comme grossouvre est comme cela nous
aurions une part de responsabilité dans
cette afrique
évidemment vous êtes rentré dans la
police pour faire ce genre de chose au
départ non et pourquoi vous avez accepté
de le faire je vais accepter de le faire
parce que comme je les dis au départ
pour nous jean edern hallier tout au
moins au début constituer un problème au
niveau de la sécurité parce que c'est
une atteinte et qui a été faite au chef
de l'état ont été chargés poser de
protéger de le protéger ou protéger on
le protège et physiquement mais on
protéger aussi son intégrité
et puis et puis il y avait l'enfant qui
aussi mazarine qui aussi été au coeur de
la faire et qui n était pas responsable
de tout ce qui se passe
donc on peut considérer aussi que la
façon dont jean edern hallier voulait
atteindre le président on n'était pas
très honnête pas plus honnête que la
façon qui a été employé pour l'en
dissuader
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et puis vous raconter daniel gambale à
la maladie de françois mitterrand la fin
du règne de françois mitterrand alors
vous ne saviez pas vous l'avez appris en
92 1 mitterrand était malade il le
savait lui depuis 1981 cancer de la
prostate
donc il a publié des bulletins de santé
falsifiés après avoir dit qu'il
publierait ses bulletins de santé il en
a publié des défauts les deux dernières
années il était devenu dites-vous
l'ombre de lui même
il y avait que quelques fidèles qui
venaient le voir c'est charasse pierre
bergé qui étaient autour de lui et plus
grand monde 1 vous vous dites d'ailleurs
que même quand on est un présent dans le
public quand on est malade et en fin de
règne a plus grand monde autour de vous
c'était assez émouvant dans l'inconnu
quand on a connu au début du premier
septennat avec mon disque ou chez
relativement tard et beaucoup de monde
qui défilaient et puis effectivement on
peut se poser la question au moment où
il n'y a plus rien à espérer de lui
parce que tout le monde savait tout le
monde savait qu'il était à la fin d'un
de sa vie et de professionnels et de sa
vie physique sur terre donc oui c'est
peut-être on peut s'interroger sur la
façon dont il est le son un oui vous il
ya une phrase terrible it la fin de
règne en poste pour un courtisan et on
pense à la mort de louis 15 couverts ça
était devenu infréquentable tellement ça
ça sentait mauvais alors si on était de
retour en 87 une hypothèse est ce que
vous voteriez pour françois mitterrand
oui malgré tout ce que vous avez vu à
l'époque où vous l'avez connu de très
près honnêtement j'ai j'ai jamais voté
pour lui mais
si je me retrouverai en 1981 comme vous
me le dites oui je revois les poules je
voterai alors vous donc en 1995 avait
été muté dans une unité traditionnel de
la gendarmerie et en 2001 vous avez mis
fin à votre carrière militaire donc
maintenant on fait quoi
plus rien je suis retraité donc je
profite je profite de la vie oui je peux
pas vous occuper de moi merci en tous
les cas daniel go
[Applaudissements]
incroyable non oui oui oui c'est
sûrement incroyable simplement peut-être
la petite chose qui me gêne là dedans
c'est que quand on entend tout ça mis
bout à bout
ouais on a un peu l'impression qu'au
fond françois mitterrand était un chef
de gang quoi et ça je demande pardon
mais d'abord je n'adhère je peux pas
adhérer à ça ça a été je crois un très
grand président de la république avec
sûrement des zones troubles comme tous
les présidents de la république
je crois que j'avais effectivement un
homme qui avait un immense respect de la
vie humaine
je crois que c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
beaucoup beaucoup pour le pays même si
on est pas on n'était pas totalement
d'accord avec ses idées mais alors je
voudrais bien qu'on ne leur ramène pas à
cette image qui encore enfant une fois
en fait une sorte de chef de gang
mafieux
il était tout à fait autre chose et
c'est quelqu'un qui d'une certaine
manière a illuminé le pays pendant un
bon moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant à la mac
un wagon soir florence moncorgé gabin
car ditty donc à la main que vous êtes
chef d'entreprise sociologues
économistes essayiste consultant favori
de tous les grands patrons et président
du conseil de surveillance du journal le
plus puissant de france
le journal le monde voilà avant ça vous
avez été un enfant de la république
j'avais commencé à l'école communale est
terminée à l'ena major de votre promo la
promo léon blum voilà alors pas mal pour
un enfant de réfugiés juifs polonais
votre père joseph avait fui la pologne
en 1931 et sa femme notre mère l'a
rejoint clandestinement un petit peu
plus tard votre père était fondateur du
journal du pcf en yiddish et pendant la
guerre il a fait partie du groupe de
résistance ftp moy voilà il était
naturalisé après la guerre c'est la
résistance finalement qui l'a fait
rentrer dans la communauté nationale
alors vous avez une enfance assez
austère s'était pas le lumpen
prolétariat
enfin c'était quand même pas facile est
il vrai que jusqu'à 10 ans vous dormiez
sur un fauteuil pliant dans la chambre
de vos parents oui mon enfance était un
lit pliant savait aller rien que de très
normal d'accord alors à 11 en revanche
je vous lis j'ai déjà le monde alors ça
c'est assez extraordinaire parce que
vous le lisiez 11 ans et je raisonne le
jour du coup d'état de mai 58 mon père
m'a dit li le monde tu comprendras pas
mais tu t'en souviendras la preuve je
m'en souviendrai cependant pas
effectivement alors vous êtes
typiquement la main qu'un un produit de
l'élitisme républicain
aujourd'hui vous vous dites libérales de
gauche en ce sens c'est un créneau très
étroits avec le seul occupant
c'est comme les monarchistes cool on
n'est pas nombreux mais je me le dis
franchement offrant une alliance et vous
publié chez grasset un livre qui qui qui
a lancé un énorme débat en france depuis
depuis sa parution et qui s'appelle
épître à nos nouveaux maîtres
et c'est chez grasset
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors le piste du livre est très simple
à la menthe dit le conformisme a changé
de camp ce n'est plus le vieux
conformisme bourgeois qui règne mais un
nouveau conformisme le politiquement
correct qui est imposée dit-il par nos
nouveaux maîtres
alors nos nouveaux maîtres sont ou
seraient selon quand on adhère ou non à
la thèse d'alain minc
les féministes les gays les
communautaristes les ong les anti
américain les anti mondialisation et et
vous dit effectivement que est en train
d'arriver en france ce qui est arrivé
aux états-unis et d'ailleurs vous dites
que françois furet en parler à chaque
fois qu'ils revenaient ils disaient
pourvu que ça n'arrive pas en france
absolument au fond je regrette de ne pas
avoir dédié ce livre à la mémoire de
françois furet cet immense historiens
qui était un vieil ami qui à chaque fois
qu'il revenait des états unis me disais
pourvu que cela nous arrive pas et il
ajoutait et cela nous arrivera les morts
avant mais cela nous est arrivé
cela nous est arrivé en en plein doute
vous politiquement correct et c'est vrai
vous dites qu aujourd'hui l'idéologie
dominante
c'est celle de ceux qui ont
l'intelligence de se présenter comme des
dominos et c'est pas qu'ils ont été
oui qui l'ont été mais qui aujourd'hui
ont l'intelligence de se présenter
encore comme les dominer quand vous
dites qu aujourd'hui on vit sous la
dictature d'un certain nombre de
minorités finalement oui sous une
pression très forte de ses minorités qui
fait qu'il ya des choses qu'on n'ose pas
dire non le comble c'est en ça que le
conformisme me semble-t-il a changé de
sens ou de camp le camp rit alors
effectivement sous les dehors sympa du
libertarisme post soixante huitard vous
dites que nous sommes victimes d'un
terrorisme intellectuel un terrorisme
soft certes mais un terrorisme quand
même écoutez je suis d'ailleurs un peu
frappé par quelques réactions que
provoque ce livre est quand même sur
certains plans assez modérée aux états
unis il apparaît très modérée
bouchonnait ça faisait des années que
j'avais pas pris une telle volée de bois
vert déjà d une mais ça me réjouit
d'ailleurs ça me donne le sentiment que
je suis plus un peu que je ne suis pas
autant bourgeois mais d'aucuns le
croient donc de ce point de vue c'est
satisfaisant
alors en plus dit vouloir moyens
d'action pour imposer ce terrorisme soft
et c'est très habile parce que d'abord
nous culpabiliser
et il faut un chantage compassionnel
c'est à dire il est regardé comment les
malheureux nous aimer les rangs étaient
là et ils l'ont été mais il ya un moment
où le ou le prime et devient à son tour
légèrement oppresseurs ils ont été
malheureux ils ont été excommuniés ils
ont été exclus
ils se sont émancipées et c'est tant
mieux mais il ya il faut savoir trouver
le juste équilibre alors les
contre-pouvoirs dites-vous sont devenus
des pouvoirs et ces bien pensants fond
de nous non seulement des mal pensants
par rapport à eux mais surtout ce que
vous regrettez c'est que nous soyons
tous des molles pensant oui alors parce
que il faut se demander pourquoi tout
ceci s'est produit et je crois que ceci
s'est produit parce que il n'y a plus
d'idées du progrès au fond tant que le
communisme existait il y avait une
utopie
même si la réalité en est l inverse en
face ce qu'il combattait croyez à une
forme de progrès aujourd'hui vous voyez
des gens qui disent le progrès avance la
société s'améliorent
notre condition et meilleur nos
aspirations sont satisfaites nous allons
y arriver il n'y a plus cette idéologie
de progrès donc chacun revient sur des
îles et des eaux logique complètement
refermé sur lui même et se sécurise dans
son petit univers alors le problème
effectivement c'est que c'est la fin du
fameux pacte républicain qui régissait
le pays depuis depuis des lustres
la société devient de plus en plus
émietté divisé en tribu et voilà quoi et
c'est la fin d'une certaine idée de la
france entière voire ce qui m'angoisse
sais que je ne suis pas sûr que des
enfants de beurre je parle même pas des
beurs aujourd'hui mais des enfants de
beurre bénéficieront du processus
extraordinaire d'intégration dans la
société française dont moi même j'ai
bénéficié et au fond c'est cette
angoisse qui sous-tend qui sont dans ce
livre
alors on va prendre ses nouveaux maîtres
un parent alors on va commencer avec les
féministes pour vous dites vous la la
lutte pour l'égalité s'est mué en un
combat pour la différence homme femme et
ça c'est la porte ouverte évidemment au
communautarisme
la preuve dit
la parité qu'on inscrit dans la
constitution la parité si vous venez au
nom non non non attendez attendez ne me
répondait pas voici isabelle alonso
[Musique]
alors ils avaient d'alonso bonsoir vous
êtes présidente des chiennes de garde
et finalement vous vous réagissez assez
assez violemment aux bouquins d'alain
minc et aux propos qu'il tient sur les
féministes quand il dit le féminisme est
la matrice involontaire du
communautarisme déjà vous involontaire
sur dire que les femmes font des choses
sans faire exprès ce qui est pas très
sympa et un peu con way donc vous dites
les femmes composent la moitié de toutes
les communautés et que finalement
accuser les féministes de la matrice de
communautarisme c'est quelque chose
d'inepte pour vous oui je trouve que
c'est pas très bien analysé enfin
j'étais j'ai été assez surprise en fait
de votre été de pitre alors vous avez
dit que c'était pas des épîtres que
j'étais un pitre non j'ai dit dans
l'épître yapi treuil
c'était pour elle fait avec plus de
raffinement et c'est ce que j'ai trouvé
effectivement que c'était c'est que
quand j'ai vu que vous vous intéressiez
au féminisme sur le moment j'étais
contente parce que je me disais c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose auquel les
les élites qui nous gouvernent et qui
nous contrôle ne ne pense pas très
souvent
donc j'étais plutôt contente et puis
quand j'ai lu votre votre texte qui fait
qu'ils aient pas très longs en même
temps donc il est assez vite lui eh ben
je m'aperçois que je suis maintenant moi
une maître à penser maîtresse à penser
que je suis devenu de deux mines et je
suis devenue dominante mais pensez si je
suis ravi parce que si moi je suis
dominante est que monsieur minc est
dominée monsieur minc
vous êtes un homme blanc quinquagénaire
français
énarque et je ne crois pas m'avancer en
disant que vous êtes hétérosexuels donc
toutes ces caractéristiques font de vous
exactement
une partie du noyau qui tient absolument
toutes les manettes du pouvoir dans ce
pays et d'ailleurs dans la planète nous
faisait la seule chose c'est que vous
allez dans 40 et maintenant 2000
et moi dominante mais je vous dis on
échange tout de suite votre position
contre la mienne je prends votre
fauteuil au mot et vous allez retrouver
les délices pari tenu pari tenu le monde
contre ruquier parle de victoire
éclatante de pouvoir absolu c'est à dire
qui dit maintenant vous avez gagné
et tenez nous dans la compétition mais
pas dans la constitution en gros il
icône à gagner et en même temps il dit
aussi dans le même texte que vous faites
un petit peu l'inventaire des inégalités
et des injustices qui subsistent elles
sont nombreuses et variées donc vous
dites il ya encore beaucoup de choses à
obtenir
vous dites aussi le féminisme c'était
mieux avant vous êtes un peu le cabrel
du féminisme c'était mieux avant c'est
également un autre quinquagénaire blanc
hétérosexuel et c'est l'autre 2 millions
d'ha énarque avait tout bon lui il est
étonnant que des caves et il est pas
content avec ce que j'essaye de dire
c'est que je crois que l'inégalité est
encore très forte pour nombre de femmes
que la manière dont les féministes
mènent leur combat et en particulier
avec ce leurre que la parité fait
qu'elle se préoccupe beaucoup moins de
ses vraies inégalités que d'avoir mis la
parité dans la constitution n'a en rien
fait progresser par les luttes sociales
oui mais bon les lys chabadabada c'est
très sympathique mais c'est pas le fond
du sujet n'est en rien fait progresser
l'égalité des cités dont les rites
hector les usines dans les entreprises
de tous ordres dans la vie réelle et que
de ce point de vue vous trompez de
combat je le crois alors la deuxième
chose qui est digne d'une nature
différente ce qui me choque dans la
parité c'est de dire que les différences
de nature l'homme et la femme font
qu'ils et elles sont plus importantes
que les différences de culture qu'une
certaine façon l'ine est plus important
que la qui je pense profondément que
l'idée qu'il y à des réalités de nature
qui demeure et qu'ils restent
prédominantes c'est l'idée la plus
réactionnaire de la terre je crois que
l'égalité et la forme normale de
progressisme
mais dire qu'à la fin des fins une femme
sera toujours différent d'un homme pour
des raisons fondamentales et qu' il faut
donc le marquer dans les textes qui
créent cette différenciation ça me
choque profondément lorsque vous dites
un max etc aux états unis par exemple
ils sont capables le système des quotas
mais comme ce n'est pas inscrit dans la
constitution un moment unique
contrairement à ce qu'on croit la cour
suprême a déclaré inconstitutionnels les
quotas ouais or il n'y a pas de quotas
supérieur à la parité alors on peut sur
la parité renverser le jeu et par
boutade il vous fait rien à faire si
vous me permettez de vous répondre par
une boutade comme je pense que les
femmes et surtout quand on voit les
jeunes générations qui sortent de
l'université sont en train d'être
meilleur que les hommes
on peut penser que la parité sera le
meilleur quotas pour les hommes parce
que nous aurons la moitié alors nous ne
la mérite pas donc ça nous rendra
service
c'est un usage répétitif du mot marteau
pilon
ça m'a fait rire quoi qu'il arrive et
ben je sais pas j'ai eu l'impression
avec ce livre d'une part que vous lisiez
pas très bien les fiches qu'on vous
donne est donc quelques la personne qui
les a lus pour vous les a pas bien lu ou
les a pas bien compris ce parce que vous
vous êtes trop intelligent pour avoir
ses interprétations là c'est vrai il est
malade mais quand même et en revanche je
trouve que nous avions une petite
fenêtre ouverte sur votre inconscient
qui moi m'a laissé son tir est un
marteau pilon revient trois fois sur 17
pages c'est beaucoup ce qui laissait
vous allez voir dans leur prochaine bon
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher
d'y voir quelque chose qui sexuelle
d'ailleurs il ya un acteur de l'année
marteau pilon
oui et non mais les miens et merci
thierry
le marteau pilon le stadium
voilà bien alors si vous êtes une espèce
de darby je comprends bien oui ce qui
concerne par exemple la parité là dessus
je suis tout à fait d'accord
pardon avec alain minc je pense pas que
la valise avait delà d'un verre oui je
ne pense pas oui absolument je pense pas
que la vérité soit là je suis absolument
pour l'égalité bien entendu d'ailleurs
il a fait une formidable pirouettes et
buttes à tout à leur expliquant quand
même que la jeune génération des dames
qui sortait l'université était bien plus
performante que les hommes et qu'à un
moment donné mal aux voix mâle dominant
de faire rouler dans sa ville ce sera
sympa vous aviez totalement raison quand
éclate le coup de tonnerre du deuxième
sexe en effet la condition féminine est
une condition aliénés et il ya une femme
qui sonne pour la première fois la
révolte en 40 ans vous avez gagné ce
combat
mais tant mieux il fallait que vous le
gagner mais ne pensez pas que vous êtes
encore dans la position le prix
maintenant on se connaît tous milieu du
gué sur la tête c'est nous qui l'avons
de pied sur la tête thierry non mais
c'est vrai faudrait des foires voir un
débat un peu sérieux rien sur ce sujet
leur est ce que je sens que déjà on va
passer à autre c'est autre chose
wasquehal est venu
oui mais quand
à la main que dans votre livre vous
parlez des gays alors ce qui vous énerve
c'est que cette communauté la communauté
gay revendique à la fois le droit à
l'indifférence et le droit à la
différence alors effectivement ils ont
maintenant dites vous tous les droits
plus celui de se constituer en lobby une
espèce de maçonnerie très puissantes
comme les autres voilà un ni plus ni
moins comme l'est les propres caste
auquel j'appartiens je fais la
comparaison
ça évitera l'argument tout à l'heure
voici jean luc romero
[Musique]
je
soit
alors jean luc romero bonsoir vous êtes
le premier membre du rpr à s'afficher
ouvertement homosexuel de werther
oui on va de l'ump est le premier élu
français à avoir fait publiquement état
de votre séropositivité aujourd'hui vous
êtes conseiller régional d'ile-de-france
est alors donc d'après alain minc
vous voulez tout c'est à dire le mariage
entre hommes bon le pacs disons
l'adoption des enfants qui étaient pour
oui je n'ai rien j'ai un petit regret la
procréation médicale assistée enfin tout
comme les autres donc mais en gardant le
droit d'être différent et vous organisés
en un lobby surpuissant alors qu'on
veuille tout j'en suis pas tout à fait
persuadé parce que dans la communauté
gay je sais pas contrairement à ce que
vous pouvez dire monsieur main qui a pas
une unité dans la communauté on veut pas
tous la même chose mais en tout cas moi
ce que je constate aujourd'hui c'est
cléguer c'est pas des citoyens comme les
autres
contrairement à ce que vous dites c'est
quand même toujours des sous citoyens
parce que c'est vrai pour cette chantage
qu'on passionne la non mais attendez en
revendique des drones dont les a pas ses
droits parce que je dis qu'on est tout
puissant
même quand on parle du pacte par exemple
quand même se rappeler que le pacs il a
été adopté dans des conditions qu'on
connaît assez difficile que ça a été
imposé aux politiques parce qu'ils n'ont
pas fait de gaieté de coeur
et puis le pacs c'est quoi c'est quand
même un sous contrat aujourd'hui même si
j'ai été favorable au pacs il faut quand
même reconnaître qu'il qu'il donne pas
beaucoup de droit est qu'aujourd'hui les
gays ne sont pas des citoyens comme les
autres donc je pense qu'il est légitime
qu'il demande des droits sans pour
autant moi je vous assure je suis
absolument contre le communautarisme ou
parler sans arrêt de communautarisme moi
j'y suis pas du tout favorable je veux
simplement qu'on ait les mêmes droits
que les autres
il faut quand même le dire aujourd'hui
c'est absolument pas le cas et que s'il
est votre vision quand même très
idyllique delà de la communauté gay je
crois que c'est peut-être une vision
enfin je sais pas si vous avez souvent
dans le marais vial et peut-être c'est
un endroit très agréable
si vous voulez on peut y aller un soir
ensemble
j étais avant vous parce que j'y suis né
vous imaginez les juifs polonais était
dans le marais avec les gays s'y
installent mais vous encensent
volontiers écoutez on ira en iran semble
même en iran semble quand même le marais
ce n'est quand même que que je l'arbre
qui cache la forêt de ce qui se passe
réellement en france parce que
aujourd'hui on al'impression d'accord on
voit beaucoup de télé de gay à la
télévision parce que ça fait peut-être
faire de l'audience j'en sais rien mais
enfin effectivement dans la vie
quotidienne
l'homophobie chez que vous contestez ce
mot aussi l'homophobie c'est quand même
c'est quand même une réalité
je conteste le mot homophobie entend
donc bien je dis pas qu'il n'ya pas une
hostilité aux gays jeudi que homophobie
ça veut pas dire hostilité aux
homosexuels ça veut dire hostilités à
l'homme c'est tout j'ai trouvé que cette
captation très habile de mots étaient
été bien fait mais c'est tout ça c'est
simple remarque est prête il évolue avec
le temps et voilà marqué c'est pas un
cas où on a changé le vocabulaire par
décret pour le féminiser sa joue droite
mais moi je suis pour la féminisation
des noms de fonction ce qui n'a pas de
nom n'existe pas et les femmes
historiquement n'existe pas parce qu'on
avait volé mon cv
vous savez que les pays où on croit que
par décret on change une langue ne sont
pas naturellement les plus démocratiques
décret pour changer le monde a changé à
l'affairé
les gens qui disent pas les bons mots on
est dit simplement dont les noms de
fonction heureusement que les peines de
prison pour des gués la culture des gays
savita n'en sais rien dire que je suis
placé je trouve que ce que j'aimerais
entendre de la part des deux ceux des
gays qui s'expriment le plus sur la
place publique et il y en a quand même
un certain nombre c'est de dire le jour
où nous aurons les mêmes droits que
chacun est bien on en viendra à ce mot
que pierre bergé utilisant disant être
homosexuel c'est comme être fauchés et
quand on joue une partie de tennis est
bien ou l'ajout autres droitiers et les
gauchers
orillia vous savez très bien une forme
de renfermement quand même à l'intérieur
de la communauté gaie comme aux états
unis venir lire san francisco se
reproduit un peu à paris qui peut faire
craint
que même quand vous aurez acquis les
droits auquel vous aspirez vous resterez
enfermé sur vous même
et d'ailleurs ça on l'a vécu aux états
unis je vais vous parler de simplement
ce que font certains grands magasins
aujourd'hui notamment en province moi
personnellement je ne serais pas
d'accord avec moi mais je trouve ça très
bien
des grands matches je ne citerai pas des
grandes enseignes ont décidé d'avoir des
départements gay des rayons gay friendly
moi je peux vous dire que c'est très
utile pour une simple raison c'est qu'en
province la plupart des personnes qui
sont gays qui sont séropositives aussi
ils n'osent pas aller demander à leurs
libraires un bouquin même dans un même
dans une grande librairie
moi je vous mangez sorties de livres
dans un dans lequel je parle de ma
séropositivité
je peux vous dire que j'ai reçu nombre
de lettres de jeunes gay de province qui
m'ont dit écoutez nous on ne peut pas
aller demander un autre ibère on peut
pas commander leurs rivales j'aurais dit
alors vous allez romero je trouve c'est
votre exemple est dit de manière très
très démonstrative et très chaleureuses
mais réfléchissez une seconde vous
acceptez est-ce que vous accepter l'idée
de penser que dans un grand magasin au
printemps vous ayez un département ou
alors les musulmans iront trouver les
vêtements qu'ils ont envie de voir où
les juifs iront chercher leur kippa ou
les guérir on à la section gay friendly
m'enfin c'est entrer dans un univers fou
mais s'est pas excusé moi accès en mai à
temps vous avez l'air de croire
qu'aujourd'hui il est simple d'être
homosexuel lors peut-être dans le marais
ivème arrondissement
il ya aucun problème mais quand vous
vivez au fin fond de la corrèze à tulle
je peux vous assurer qu être homosexuel
aujourd'hui même si à paris on sait pas
ce que ça suppose pas de dire qu'un
magasin qu'un magasin face aux jambes
alors pas péno
puis sa part et n'aimant jeu là aussi je
suis sur le principe tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que vous êtes en train
dénoncer et en même temps un je voulais
vous dire d'abord que ce que vous avez
fait très bien d'avoir pris d'avoir eu
le courage on puisse compter les hommes
politiques c'est sûrement pas de la
tarte
parce que c'est pas un milieu surtout
non mais peu importe alors je me joins à
votre mage parce que ça devait pas être
commode je suis sur l'histoire du
magasin d'accord avec un à main que je
pense que puisque vous êtes un homme
politique
vous avez donc des responsabilités par
rapport au peuple auquel vous appartenez
au pays dans lequel vous vivez
je pense que le combat serait peut-être
plus juste je suis pas plus utile mais
plus juste si vous puissiez au fond je
crois que le combat serait d'expliquer
aux gens de la province qu'à un moment
donné
non seulement il n'y aura pas de
cloisonnement que ce cloisonnement est
indigne parce que ce sport là aussi
pourquoi pas remettre étoile pendant
qu'on y est mais qu'au contraire il est
tout à fait naturel que ces choses là
existe naturellement dans un rayon de
magasins parce que ça fait partie de la
vie et que la vie d'un homme auxiette ou
d'un homosexuel n'est pas inférieure à
celle d'un hétérosexuel et qui s'en faut
de beaucoup je pense que le vrai combat
se situe là et je pense que c'est ça que
vous voulez dire
et justement voir notre politique c'est
que faire un ordonner de taper du poing
sur la table pour dire écoutez
maintenant ça suffit ce sont dorénavant
ce sera comme ça il ya des gauchers dans
la société française dégâts c'est vrai
mais ça se décrète pas malheureusement
non
on se marre
bien que nous on connait dans votre
soutien il se dit en effet compter le
nombre de place dans votre livre
communautariste dans la patrie de la
laïcité s'entend après la séparation de
l'église et de l'état
on parle effectivement de communautés
musulmanes de communautés juives et
quand vous voyez d'ailleurs deux cent
mille juifs qui manifestent contre
l'antisémitisme et pour la solidarité
avec israël
vous dites c'est absurde oui mais c'est
un peu trop se faire de service et na
waie si gilles william goldnadel
[Musique]
oui
passe
alors gilles william goldnadel bonsoir
vous êtes avocat international vice
président de l'association france israël
auteur d'un livre intitulé le nouveau
bréviaire de la haine que vous avez là
antisémitisme et antisionisme qu'est
publié chez ramsay
alors voilà mardi c'est la fin du
melting potes on est très loin de
l'assimilation la communauté juive est
de plus en plus repliée sur elle même
oui enfin d'abord je veux dire que je me
sens très proche d'alain minc
mais ce que je lui reproche très
amicalement et c'est pour ça qu'il m'a
déçu c'est que c'est peut-être un
paradoxe c'est s'agissant de la
communauté dont il est le plus proche
c'est là où son analyse me paraît
peut-être que mes amis gays considère
que je suis gay d'honneur saluant des
voisins dans le marais donc que c'est
possible aussi enfin vous vous ne cachez
pas vous origines juives mais pas plus
pas plus que moi non mais je vous ai
repris sur ce mot parce que c'est très
révélateur
je dis que je suis juif et jeudi sous
forme de boutade que je suis plus
mauvais juif de paris ce à quoi un jour
robert badinter m'a dit que vous êtes
présomptueux ce qui était assez longue
non mais et vous dites la communauté
mais la comité dont vous êtes le plus
proche ça veut dire que c'est un ancrage
fondamentale et l'ancrage dominant chez
moi ça veut dire ça or moi je ne sais
pas quel mon ancrage dominant le move
vous avez employé la vraie expression de
notre vraie divergence non je crois
maintenant notre vraie divergence est
sûre le mot communautarisme sur le mot
communauté je pense qu'il n'y a pas
d'exception péjoratif du mauvais temps
mais sans présenter je considère j'ai
d'ailleurs j'essaye d'employés mais pas
de communauté mais vous n'hésitez pas
quand même dans le débat à dire d'où
vous venez
m mes salutations les mots et parce que
ce mois demandé si vous me demander ma
définition je me sens juifs au sens
sartrien c'est à dire juif par le regard
des autres portent un nom juif voilà
s'est tous dit plus ni moins mais je
pense qu'il ya des mondes culturels des
idées forme d'identité culturelle
mais ce que je n'aime pas le mot
communauté c'est un mot qui en faire
mais je le retenais mes jeux est ce que
vous me permettez pour illustrer ce
propos de revenir à la
première chose que thierry a dit qu' et
j'ai été très choqué par la
manifestation des deux cent mille
personnes qui étaient contre l'entité
jour la seule déception des béninois
fait des macarons d'être l'avocat devant
l'avocat et de tours la solidarité avec
israël que les juifs manifestent contre
l'antisémitisme d'abord dans cette
manifestation il n'y aurait pas que des
juifs
dieu merci que certains juifs disent par
ailleurs qu'une partie de la communauté
juive se sentent j'emploie lave le mot
communautés liées à israël une partie
d'accord d'ailleurs est lié à israël
c'est pas nécessairement soutenir le
gouvernement de l'instant du pays ce qui
est une nuance
mais dire que tout combat par l'anti
c'est pour l'un contre l'antisémitisme
va de pair avec la solidarité avec lui
israël ça me choque profondément ma main
si bien c'est que derrière que toutes
les personnes qui ne seraient pas
d'accord avec la politique d'israël
sauvé ça veut dire ça veut dire que le
lien avec israël prend l'ascendant sur
les autres formes de lire mais ça veut
dire que au fond parce que vous êtes
juif vous vous sentez vaguement
solidaire du gouvernement sharon est
profondément solidaires d'israël alors
que vous pouvez être juif considéré qu'
israël a bien sûr le droit à exister que
c'est un engagement de la communauté
internationale peut-on espérer pour les
siècles des siècles mais qu'il empêche
que son gouvernement est dirigé par un
soudard et qu' il doit être combattue au
post il se défendre mais qui doit être
combattue comme tout gouvernement
c'est aussi à la main excusez moi mais
on peut être juif et anti sioniste ou à
sioniste ouest
heureusement heureusement d'ailleurs la
chose qui est vrai c'est qu'on sait
qu'il y a des formes d'antisionisme qui
sont que la traduction de
l'antisémitisme et qu'il fallait pas
avoir leur l'ouïe fine pour entendre les
3500 ong à la conférence de durban qui
tenait des propos qui étaient dignes
des protocoles des sages de sion et des
années 30 ça c'est une évidence
il n'empêche que il y a dans la relation
ou la manière dont l'un certain nombre
de juifs vivent leur relation à israël
quelque chose qui fait qu'ils pensent
que ce lien est un lien constitutif de
leur identité avant toute chose et a
alors quand vous dites que nous avons
envenimer le débat je ne lâchais gp de
l'huile schilb a dit ça mais attendez ce
sera mon dernier mot ce sera de dire ce
ne serait pas dit vous avez des univers
le débat racial que tu fais tu là vous
vous faites une confusion qui est une
confusion qui fonde une forme de
communautarisme juif mais ça c'est notre
dixième chance mais c'est là excusez moi
c'est plus facile avec les féministes et
les gays qu'avec les gelures un genou
bien vite il a calé quelle est votre
réaction quand vous voyez gilles william
goldnadel qui dit à la main que la
communauté dont vous êtes le plus proche
c'est à dire que avant de voir l'homme
d'affaires l'essayiste l'énarque peu
importe il voit le juif c'est le droit
dans la main que de penser que la
communauté par communauté à laquelle il
appartient ses origines juives ne sont
pas plus importantes qu'un certain
nombre d'autres choses qui croise
résistance ça en fait partie
sans plus voilà moi je suis un faux j je
le dis tout de suite que si je suis un
vieux de la religion juive
je suis un faux juste puisque je suis
juif que de par mon père mais comme je
suis un juif laïc finalement ça m'a un
peu importe là encore je pense que ce
que mme un caddie et failli tout à fait
proche de ce que je pense moi on peut
évidemment descendre dans la rue pour
lui que tu portes pour dire qu'on est
contre l'antisémitisme
je leur ai fait on peut bien entendu
défendre pour descendre dans la rue pour
défendre le droit du peuple et
israéliens a existé personne n'a pas
sauté dans les restaurants pierre arditi
tout simplement mes valeurs à ce que
veut dire que c'était ça la manif ou non
mais la manifestation c'était ça ne
s'était pas soutien à sharon soutiennent
que ce soit bien clair une bonne fois
pour toutes ce pays la palestine israël
ce pays il faudra bien à un moment donné
que ces deux communautés ces deux
peuples s'entendre une bonne fois pour
toute ils ont des droits des deux côtés
il faudra qu'il soit
série
alors à main que dans votre livre vous
en prenez également aux petits juges de
synonymes de redresseur de sport si les
derniers instants et avide de toujours
plus de pureté à travers des
instructions mais si à grand spectacle à
la main qu'on ne me répondez pas ne me
répondez pas car voici
[Musique]
qui va
ainsi le juge eric halphen
il les a tous alors eric halphen bonsoir
et magistrats en disponibilité et auteur
d'un livre intitulé ces temps de
solitude
alors quand alain minc parle de
complexes médiatico judiciaire comme il
existe aux usa un complexe militaro
industriel
quand il dit que tous les petits juges
comme vous et petit juste là c'est un
compliment 1
voyez vous êtes avide de notoriété ça
vous fait quoi
à écouter d'abord moi contrairement à
goldnadel je ne me sens pas extrêmement
proche d'alain minc
cela étant j'ai noté quand même qu'il
avait magistralement québécois kidal
qu'il avait en quelque sorte jeté une
fleur aux jure une fleur une simple
fleur en disant que finalement on avait
quand même une action positive pour la
démocratie
ouais donc ça c'est un point positif
cela étant après je trouve que il a un
peu tendance à ne voir dans les juges
que ceux dont on parle
ouais il n'y a pas que les juges qui
s'occupe du pénal y aussi des juges qui
s'occupe du civil y'a pas qui est juste
qui s'occupe des affaires médiatiques
aux financières ou politico financières
il ya des juges qui tous les jours
quotidiennement font leur travail dans
leur cabinet sans que personne ne leur
demande rien et quant au complexe de la
notoriété parce que j'avoue que souvent
c'est un peu c'est un peu des phrases
qu'on retrouve un peu partout à savoir
les juges en fait ils ne font des
perquisitions que pour comprendre il ne
convoque les gens que pour les caméras
ils sont avides de voir leur nom dans
les journaux leur tête à la télé d'abord
moi je dois dire que personnellement je
ne me suis pas sentie visée puisque j'ai
toujours refusé d'aller sur les plateaux
de télé tant que j'étais en fonction
c'est vrai première chose et deuxième
chose être juge c'est quand même le seul
métier qu on n'exerce pas pour avoir la
notoriété dont on est sportif
a priori quand ça marche on devient un
peu célèbre quand on est comédien
également quand on est juge
on s'attend uniquement à chercher la
vérité vous pensez qu'il vous fait un
mauvais procès à la main quand fait qu'
il part du principe assiette bon procès
mais effectivement on ne cherche pas la
morale on cherche tout simplement ce que
les gens respectent les lois notamment
quand il s'agit des joueurs viennent
note
je peut plaider ma cause l'avocat parce
que dans votre bouquin il ya un loup
contre les chevaux courrier est-ce que
vous accepteriez le raisonnement suivant
que je crois que je fais dans le bouquin
qui est dire
il est clair que la justice avait besoin
d'être émancipée et qui avait nécessité
d' une forme d'égalité face à la loi
qu'on a de ce point de vue et je le dis
fait un progrès considérable
ce que je crois c'est qu'il est en train
de se passer en france qui va se passer
en france ce qui s'est passé en italie
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné ce
complexe médiatico judiciaire parce que
là je persiste et je signe même si à
cause de ça ils enlèvent le sur sni
jeudi que ce complexe médiatico
judiciaire est en train d'aller
tellement loin qu'à un moment l'opinion
se retourne et que finalement l'italie
est en train de revenir à l'opacité
ce que je crois on a disséqué avoir des
nuages on agit pour chercher la vérité
c'est là ce que ja que je suis parce que
je crois le biais de que votre
institution est en train de prendre
c'est que le contre-pouvoir est devenu
pouvoir vous n'étiez rien vous êtes en
fin de compte rien voir ne me raconter
par sa mère et vous êtes en train de
meilleur mot avec le président de la
république actuel est passé entre les
mailles de justice il y avait un vrai
pouvoir judiciaire n'en serais pas où on
en est aujourd'hui je pense
il ya une autre idée reçue ce serait une
espèce de ce qu'on a appelé l'alliance
où la sainte alliance entre les juges et
le journaliste et alain minc de donner
l'exemple des plaintes avec constitution
de partie civile qui sont portées à la
connaissance du public dès qu'elles sont
déposées oui mais justement elles sont
déposées le plus souvent auprès du doyen
des juges d'instruction
et avant même que le juge soit saisi ça
tombe dans le domaine public
c'est tout simplement parce qu'il ya
d'autres personnes que les juges qui
peuvent parler aux journalistes
il ya les policiers ils seraient les
avocats
ya un bon nombre de parrains et c'est
une vision un peu superficielle des
choses moins de penser que ce ne sont
que les juges c'est à dire une chose
souvent avec alpha nos cils et les juges
ont donné non les dossiers aux
journalistes non non les affaires qui se
comprendre j'ai écrit dans mon livre il
est beaucoup plus mince et la voulait
faire donner oui il est que les deux
intéressant pour un journaliste de se
mettre dans la poche un ou deux avocats
qui vont avoir un bon nombre d'affaires
dans le temps et donc c'est un
investissement rentable qu'un juge qui
ne sera qu'une affaire entre guillemets
médiatique et en conséquence c'est pas
un investissement intéressant pour le
royaliste
il ya beaucoup plus de journalistes qui
ont des copains avocat un des copains
juge suis désolé bien merci beaucoup
eric halphen pierre arditi
donc j'ai une opinion sortie c'est à
dire qu'il est très rare que des
comédiens ont bien s'exprimer sur des
sujets sérieux donc on y tient on en
profite c'est eric macé ça bon alors je
vais encore enfilé une paire d'années
plus rien et je peux je peux pas dire
grand chose là sinon une chose peut-être
que c'est à vous que j'ai envie de la
dire c'est que quand vous dites qu'au
fond votre boulot et vous avez raison
c'est de faire que la justice soit la
même pour tous bien sûr que c'est votre
boulot que vous le vouliez ou non et
même si vous là pour le coup vous n'en
êtes pas forcément responsable elle
n'est pas la même pour tous aujourd'hui
parce que le pouvoir des médias est-elle
pouvoir l'opinion publique et de telles
que quand vous faites une instruction
sur quelqu'un qu'on ne connaît pas et
qui est un lampiste quelqu'un qui est
totalement inconnu et vous preniez
quelqu'un qui est dans la lumière des
projecteurs qui est un homme public ou
une femme publique
que vous le vouliez ou non et même si
vous ne voulez pas le la donnée n'est
pas la même et même si vous ne donnez
pas vos informations aux médias
d'abord on les donne je ne dis pas que
c'est vous qui les donner mais les
médias s'en emparent et à partir du
moment de ce moment-là ça éclabousse la
personnalité de l'homme ou de la femme
en question on a vu ça pour les
politiques
on a vu qu'ils ne sont plus du tout
qu'ils soient traités de la même manière
que les autres très bien qu'ils soient
traités pire que les autres noms et or
on voit aujourd'hui qu'ils sont plutôt
traitée plus mal que les autres
et aujourd'hui la présomption
d'innocence a cessé d'exister enfin oui
mais ça excusez moi de vous dire c'est
une vision un peu parisien des choses
non parce que parce que la personne
entendue
la personne dans son village qui mise en
examen pour des viols pour des meurtres
pour des braquages et après on
s'aperçoit qu'elle est innocente quand
elle ressort de prison l'opprobre et
continue à être sur l anneau opel et
saab comme ça ils corrigent connais je
ne veux pas mais georges de vis en corée
on n'a laissé tomber personne hommes
politiques tels que soit leur corps est
difficile a dit hugo reis est beaucoup
plus n'as absolument salies et qu'on a
découvert trois blessés la terre aucun
salaire dans les journaux il y avait
deux lignes à la dernière page des
journaux qu'il avait fait les premières
passes pendant des semaines et des
semaines on est quand même obligé
d'évoquer le problème qu'on valait bien
jeune weeks et brookhaven non mais j'ai
bien compris je dis qu'à ce moment là
qu'on le veuille ou non la justice n'a
pas le même impact et le même poids ça
selon qu'on est monsieur durand vous
prenez par exemple celle du maintenant
mais ça d'abord à canon je vous laisse
conclure c'est fini le passage à tabac
attend de voir sortir
pas dans la poche je vous laisse le
dernier mot à la non écoute et d'autres
débats étaient plus nuancées que je
croyais c'est à dire que au fond je
pense qu'on a quand même tous le
sentiment que vous croyez qu'il faut
aller plus loin dans les combats que
vous menez mais vous admettez qu'à la
fin il ne faut pas qu'ils aient de
communauté et qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
société de citoyens
je suis ravi de vous l'entendre dire
aussi clairement
donc moi au fond j'ai le sang j'ai le
sentiment d'avoir entendu des propos qui
me rassure très bien merci
et puis cela nous
tiens ici
chez vous libérez merci d'avoir été
alléché new moon en parlant à peine une
leçon de savoir vivre
écrit par jean claude
c'est à 18h france tous les soirs ota
dirigé par jean michel ribes avec
beaucoup de succès merci merci pierre
arditi
merci
m
j'accueille maintenant beyris béjo
sa mère
bien alors bérénice mais je vous avais
été révélée au grand public grâce à
l'excellent film de gérard jugnot
meilleur espoir féminin qui vous a valu
d'ailleurs d'être nommé pour un meilleur
espoir féminin aux césars voilà à
l'époque où jugnot chercher une
comédienne pour le rôle vous doutiez de
votre vocation
vous avez décidé de vous donner encore
une chance et d'aller faire finalement
ce set et c'est assez ça oui
vous étiez prêt à raccrocher les gants à
l'époque disons que j'ai été un peu loin
de des films que j'avais envie de faire
et j'avais dit à ma meilleure amie j'en
ai marre si quelque chose se passe pas
maintenant je j'arrête quoi voilà ça
s'est passé
deux jours après le premier essai film
est pour meilleur espoir féminin la
production vous appelle pour venir lire
un monologue et vous arrivez avec une
heure et demie de retard pas de métro
panne de bagnols mais ça marche et quand
même jugnot a complètement flashé sur
vous 1
il a eu raison que seul un film cette
excellente alors ensuite il ya eu un
virus appelé cheval here un blockbuster
médiéval au rock
ensuite il ya eu le film de marie france
pisier comme un avion
et aujourd'hui 24 heures de la vie d'une
femme de laurent bouhnik adapté par
laurent bouhnik et gilles taurand à
partir d'un livre de stefan zweig avec
michel serrault agnès jaoui et vous
alors voulez que je fasse le pitch vous
le faites sur l'histoire
ouais moi je le fais malaisie volontiers
alors 24 heures de la vie d'une femme
c'est l'adaptation du roman de zergs et
et
et dans le sud aux cours normaux en deux
vagues il ya deux époques c'est une
femme qui raconte comment 24 heures de
sa vie ont changé sa vie elle a
rencontré l'amour une passion charnelle
et intense et laurent bouhnik et gilles
taurand ont voulu rajouter une époque
donc l'époque deux mille deux mille 2000
dans laquelle je suis là michel serrault
et le jeune homme à qui agnès jaoui
raconte l'histoire donc voilà c'est pas
mal non mais c'est plusieurs flash back
ça se passe dans trois écoles et erronée
et c'est vrai que cette femme donc à
vous un jeune enfant sa conduite avec
entonne un joueur invétéré avec qui elle
a passé ses fameuses 24 heures et que ce
jeune enfant on le retrouve
effectivement à l'aube du troisième
millénaire sous les traits de michel
serrault et il est effectivement ils
flashent il flashe sur vous ça c'est
clair j'ai toujours été très très nul
pour raconter des histoires mouammar a
quand même non ça va ecoutez-vous
l'agora on regarde à quoi ressemble mon
mari ballon et magnéto serge
[Musique]
je suis toujours demandé pourquoi betty
dès le premier soir avec un bassiste et
pour mon équipe mais je crois que ce
n'était pas seulement pour chasser les
idées noires
peut-être que sans le savoir hollande
distraire elle se venger en vérité de
toutes ces années de souffrance
[Musique]
les premières machines de 100 mille
francs de pertes
cette nuit lors d'une lutte effrénée
part il s'agissait bien de la vie de
l'âme warda maman je sentais ce garçon
au bord de la vie
il me fallait aller jusqu'au bout de mon
désir de le sauver
[Musique]
l'admr écoles et son drôle de me
semblait tellement médiocre ma famille
effectué je rencontre et je n'arrivais
même pas ressembler en dame
on raconter tout ça parce que je ne n'ai
jamais dit à personne
[Musique]
c'est notre secret c'est la première
fois de ma vie que 24 heures de la vie
d'une femme de laurent bouhnik d'après
stefan zweig avec agnès jaoui michel
serrault et bérénice bejo qui est notre
invité ce soir
alors ça fait quoi tu joues avec 0 c'est
extraordinaire ouais c'est vraiment
quelqu'un d'hyper accessible de très
simple et j'ai vraiment été assez bluffé
par lui parce que c'est devenu un
compagnon me raconter sa carrière ses
anecdotes et pas du tout star sur un
piédestal inaccessible vraiment très
proches ouais très simple donc ça a été
de deux mois très très agréable et agnès
jaoui été sympa avec vous bahia soirée
jg patois passionne ensemble la seule
chose dont on a parlé quand on s'est vus
c'était de notre scène d'amour parce
qu'on avait toutes les deux au coeur de
notre première fois à l'écran nu comme
ça et tout alors on en est sorti intact
facile quand même non ouais c'est
difficile c'est difficile parce que bon
on se retrouve tout d'un coup nuit avec
quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas et et c'est
pas évident moi c'était mon premier jour
de tournage en plus le mec je l'avais
rencontrée une fois la veille
salut ça va tu vas faire votre âme bien
que super ouais alors c'est sympa comme
métier bah écoutez ça s'est mieux passé
un bon travail et vous diriez quoi
public pour le convaincre de venir voir
votre film mais je leur dirai tout
simplement que ça parle d'amour et
passion que c'est magnifique c'est super
bien tournée qu'il ya des images
extraordinaires une musique sublime que
vraiment tout est mis en valeur tout est
là pour vous pour vous plaire pour
servir le spectateur et qu'on a tous
pris énormément de plaisir à le faire
il est bon soit en monica c'est lui qui
a fait onze ans et madeleine
ouais alors vous avez plus de doute sur
votre cas ya maintenant ça va vous être
gonflé à bloc
non j'ai quand même vachement de peur
toujours bon je crois que c'est ce que
j'ai envie de faire et je crois que
ouais j'ai continué oui parce que depuis
l'âge de 9 ans quand on vous demande et
je voulais faire dans la vie vous
écriviez actrice donc j'ai envie d'être
actrice maintenant ben ça dépend des
autres du désir des autres et envies du
désir des autres voilà dans ce métier
alors ça s'appelle 24 heures donc dans
la vie d'une femme il ya une bande son
un qui est sorti sur un cd qui est
vachement bien
[Musique]
voilà 24 heures dans la vie d'une femme
alors quand on a l'esprit tordu on va
vous faire une interview 24 heures dans
la vie d'un homme
alors organiser des jo si vous deviez
vie 24 heures dans la vie d'un homme
vous appelleriez comment d'abord thomas
thomas béjo si je vous ai déjà pensé
thomas c voilà la première chose que
vous feriez si vous étiez un homme
pendant 24 heures
bah je sais pas agir aux toilettes je
pense aller de bois ou debout assis
debout de bouteilles quel endroit vous
gratte auriez si vous étiez dans les
concerts je vois le regardant au mois
d'août à son image et à la digérer
celui-ci j'ai vu j'ai vu au caire ce que
vous vouliez oui je dois à qui irait
vous casser la gueule à ma voisine du
dessous quoi ah ouais sécher est sorti
du coeur mais voilà ces sorties du coeur
elle est comment aller chiante un casque
est rien et que je fais du bruit à
l'htap en dessous et viendront à midi
musette maladroit vous faites tomber les
choses par terre j'ai bah oui je vis
quoi vous venez pas habiter au dessus de
chez moi ne sais pas moi aussi alors
votre gros mots favoris si vous étiez un
mec s'est fait chier comme pour une
finale qu'est ce que vous penseriez des
femmes vous diriez quoi sur les femmes
si vous étiez un mètre carré sont
extraordinaires ah ben ouais vous n'êtes
pas encore un mec adore ça
n'importe quoi
coup de bol bien alors si vous étiez un
homme pendant 24 heures puisque c'est le
jeu que penseriez-vous des filles qui
couchent le premier soir j'ai saltor ah
ouais c'est un homme vous seriez slip ou
caleçon
moi je préfère les garçons mais
j'essaierai les slips juste pour savoir
ce que ça fait de l'avoir bien en
concédant slip
vous seriez vous soyez be ou hétéro bi
bi a garé son village et un petit
passage à vide mais j'imagine bien avec
quelle animatrice de télé riez vous
dînez si vous étiez un mec
franchement j'en sais rien je regarde
pas la télé donc je dis moi des noms
puis je verrai j'ai pas à laurence
ferrari n est pas mal mais je vois pas
du tout comment faire chazal non mais
daniela lumbroso von brunn vraiment
sympathique quoi une brune vraiment
alonso annonce
bah ouais vous n'êtes pas mal ma mère
avait besoin
est-ce que vous coucher le premier soir
avec cette animatrice de télévision
bah oui je pense que ça se passera bien
non à moi je mets premier soir le
premier après midi mois
24 ans
delors monica la gagner
j'ai mal à mes yeux
d
et maintenant
ouais si marc lavoine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va très bien doit être proféministes
vous parce que j'ai vu la façon dont
alonso vous a accueilli on s'aime
beaucoup adresser d'abord j'ai l'air
assez ça je suis venu rien que pour ça
vous savez à la menthe bombers parti
marc lemoine c'est un mec qui sympa avec
les filles qui est pas macho qui sait ça
ah je peux vous dire il est sexy grave
aïe ça c'est vrai leur rebond c'est un
sexy boy
la voile on vous a vu un petit peu plus
tôt dans la soirée sur le plateau de la
légende des voix une émission voilà une
émission animée par notre ami n'est ce
que je salue ici je peux partir d'israël
et bien un petit chat j'aime le filet je
sais que tu as le live de la carte n'est
demain car ce n'est que je conseille
effectivement ces bigots qui m'a filé
que ça c'est génial
assimiler un port on ne trouve pas
encore conserver alors donc vous étiez
dans cette émission se seraient bien
passés à bien elle est bien maintenant
oui elle marche bien on la soutient
attention moi aussi j'aime beaucoup
naissent alors voilà donc ça nous a mis
l'eau à la bouche on a entendu quelques
chansons de vous mon envie d'en
apprendre plus donc c'est comment on
fait ici on fait didier
bravo
j'ai dû elle aussi
allez
les
[Musique]
c'est
quand
[Musique]
mais c'est humain
quand
[Musique]
salon ces
m6
mouss
[Musique]
je
qui
c'est ça
[Musique]
il
le prince le bull
non
[Musique]
mélanie
mais
com
c'est
jours
je sens
si je me
je suis
oui
[Musique]
le
ces parts
vous
bravo marqueur alors
[Applaudissements]
qu'elle soit mineure est extraordinaire
avec vous marc lavoine c'est qu'à chaque
fois a doublé dans cette émission on
repasse toutes vos chansons et à chaque
fois on est vachement content donc tout
va bien je vais vous dire un truc c'est
que petit à petit chanson après chanson
ben vous vous installez vos débuts comme
ça on vous prenez juste pour un beau
gars et maintenant vous installez un
chanson française comme un grand de la
chanson française
et c'est bien on voit bien quand on suit
tout ça jean-luc c'est vrai je lui
disais tout à l'heure
enfin je veux pas je pas le métier mais
c'est aussi une icône gay alors c'est
moi j'ai tous ses disques comme les
trois quarts des gays il fait partie
patrimoine des faits allégués
tous les gars j'ai cherché main qui va
parler de communautarisme ça va être
chaud alors dans le dernier album il y
avait une chanson qui a eu beaucoup de
succès c'est donc un duo avec cristina
marocco que c'était j'ai tout oublié
et puis il ya un autre duo a aussi
décidément un qui marche encore mieux
j'ai l'impression si avec claire keim ça
s'appelle je ne veux qu'elle est on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble magnéto
serge
raison ne sais pas
[Musique]
ton
qui
le temps
je
on
[Musique]
n'a rien à voir avec les akènes alors
cet album donc votre huitième album
marc lavoine est réédité dans un coffret
où il ya le cd et puis un dvd ça c'est
je crois que la première fois où on met
un nom je sais pas si c'est la pro b kg
jamais vu ça donc dans le dvd il ya un
making of de l'enregistrement de l'album
et puis un certain nombre de clips un c4
les quatre clips de la ligue 1
[Musique]
ça fait rire alonso je veux y ajoute un
sourire sur rien de la diète heures
[Musique]
alors voilà dont marc lavoine tourné en
france un bientôt
et puis l'olympia du 21 au 25 janvier
c'est important ouais tout pour vous
parce que vous avez été ouvreur à
l'olympia donc maintenant faire quatre
jours à l'olympia en suisse l'état
écoute c'est vraiment incroyable
j'ai toujours habité dans le quartier de
l'impôt c'était pratique la partie bien
loin comme je connais pas de voiture moi
je j'ai mérité dans les gens voient ces
centrales de l'intérieur et puis c'est
vrai que c'est eux qui m'ont logé nourri
blanchi pendant trois ou quatre ans j'ai
accueilli avec ma troupe de théâtre dans
laquelle je bossais nous avait prêté la
salle de billard la place à des biens au
dessus de l'indien ensuite c'est eux qui
m'ont envoyé aux éditions du rideau
rouge qui m'ont fait passer des
auditions et serge rousseau à l'époque
était le grand agent de deux verres de
depardieu qui est venu seul
auditionné à l'olympia et puis vont ils
m'ont présenté les producteurs avec
lesquels je suis toujours les
compositeurs comme fabrice aboulker ça
je leur dois beaucoup
si je vous dois le duo est claire keim
grâce à tout le monde en parle à
l'olympia je dois beaucoup
donc mme arcamone olympia du 21 au 25
janvier
alors juste un mot comme ça vous
parrainez marque depuis le douzaine
d'années une association qui s'appelle
le papotin c'est le nom d'un journal
publié par de jeunes handicapés mentaux
bel esprit nous en dire un mot ben oui
ça fait quinze ans que ces jeunes
écrivent et interviews veut des artistes
des artistes d'art contemporain des
comédiens des philosophes et puis bon on
a fait donc une trentaine de numéros et
puis dernièrement c'est vrai que les
hommes politiques se sont intéressés de
près à ce projet parce que c'est une
manière différente de de mélanger la
société avec ses exclus et on y perd
beaucoup on ne ne vivent pas avec les
handicapés avec les dents
avec les raffineries on vit encore très
proche et très ensemble donc c'est vrai
que bertrand delanoë
claude allègre bayrou jack lang et puis
dernièrement évidemment jacques chirac
qui a accepté de faire une interview de
trois heures dans son bureau avec douze
jeunes aux autistes
ça ça a donné une dynamique une
dimension un petit peu différent donc il
s'agit maintenant de faire peut-être un
livre chez elle
[Applaudissements]
décidément ce matelas roanne n'a pas que
des beaux yeux bleus du bleu que le bleu
de ses yeux
je ne vois rien de mieux même le bleu
des yeux
alors vous savez marc lavoine que les
téléspectateurs peuvent poser des
questions par mail aux invités de
l'émission alors vous c'est pas du
baratin j'ai reçu un mail etc c'était
bien marc lavoine vous est désespérant
de gentillesse
oui pouvez-vous enfin dire du mal de
quelqu'un
marc fait un effort je sais que pour
vous c'est et riom mais ce que je me
mets à votre place vous pourriez dire du
mal de quelqu'un vraiment une fois dans
votre vie non je trouve qu'on peut agir
contre les gens qu'on aime pas à dire
voter descendre dans la rue prendre
position travaille dans une association
pour améliorer la vie des gens qu'on
aime contre ce qui ne les regarde pas
avec ses enfants
moi j'ai un enfant qui vit aux états
unis qui est métisse le 11 septembre ça
a été important pour les gens les blacks
aux états unis donc mon fils par exemple
leur donner une éducation pour ses 2es
les chansons aussi l'attitude qu'on a un
peu partie du mal du mal de quelqu'un je
jure le dire c'était le même visuel on
dire du mal d'un extrême droite ou dire
du mal des nains les antisémites des
anti gay des jeux fait dans mes chansons
j'écris c'est ça la france pour sa
chanson sur la prostitution pour ça avec
ravalec effet des films sur la guerre
d'espagne pour démonter les mécanismes
fasciste je m'inscris dans des avec des
gens je crois que c'est important comme
les restos du coeur ce pas une personne
c'est plusieurs personnes qui agissent
contre les mauvaises personnes je pense
que c'est sans espoir là je suis parti
dans ses retranchements j'ai fait une
connerie je suis parti dans un truc
genre d'accord je vois chez vous des
gens comme serait manuelle ou quand même
je vois l'action de personnes qui n'ont
jamais dit du mal des autres mais qui
ont nom justement c'est les gens qui
agit en reste et bien je trouve que
leurs actes sont plus éloquents que les
discours en discours et les silences en
disent non donc j'y arriverai pas j'y
arriverai pas là non
je n'arriverais pas non parce que ça
sert à pas grand chose d'énorme
vous voulez pas dire du match mais
franchement je me battrai contre moi si
je devais dire du mal je suis quelqu'un
de gentil c'est vrai c'est pour ça que
je vous demande ça alors j on passe un
peu pour dégrader si la ive d abc
l'heureux et non un peu se battre on
peut se battre sérieusement contre des
choses qui nous révolte sans pour ce à
dire du mal bon bah je crois que 1
je crois que j'ai raté mon coup
m
bon j'ai près tout cela on passe au
blind test ce soir à blind test spécial
bonaventure et aux platines
je n'ai pas philippe corti ce soir
gemini me g paolo calia
oh
[Musique]
oui
la part locale ya un excellent
décorateur qui a travaillé d'ailleurs
avec federico fellini qui ce soir
remplace philippe corti pour jouer avec
nous ce soir
arnaud gidoin et john dowland heures
m
vignes jusqu'à travailler aussi
oui
[Musique]
la tension alors donc c'est pas
compliqué on va faire l'équipe de
isabelle alonso contre l'équipe de
bérénice béjo voilà des très attention
vous connaissez le principe je veux le
nom de l'interprète évidemment ne me
donnait pas le nom de la chanson rika
zaraï voilà ça peut arriver
effectivement attention didier
j'entends du string c'est pas ça
offspring c'est très bien sauf que ça
comptait pas les offsprings c'est juste
le général du blender
je vous demande de vous arrêter
je vous demande de vous arrêter j'ai
compris bon attention aux eaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un gone 10 à l'heure où
seo pour l'équipe de bérénice béjo
attention ce concert
attention aux chinois en question
alors mes amis nîmois aux platines déjà
exactement c'est mignon ces mini miss et
mon ami paolo calia king power d'havas a
il est parfait les attentions par l'eau
allait falloir la terrebonne
[Musique]
je voudrais dire les amis dit que si par
exemple on souffre ici imaginez que ce
soit vous qui souffre lier le point va
cette éclipse imaginer que ce soit vous
souffriez en images il soit vous qui
souffre liés non isabelle sinon celles
qui souffrent ici souffle et souffler
pour faire plaisir l'équipe de bérénice
bejo attention vous êtes prêts pau
[Applaudissements]
attention les trois mois sont deux marc
lavoine pour le moment attention paul
wen
prête jamais
mais
les jeunes viennent
les semis
zen attention ça fait quatre points pour
l'équipe d'alonso attention par l'eau
[Applaudissements]
cette plage publique tu as vu à son
pelage attention par l'eau
jure devant
je demande à m
alors
marc lavoine matin
bravo
c'était assez insupportable parce que le
mec est beau il a une femme superbe
récit des chansons guelma il a du coeur
il fait le papotin il veut pas dire une
force
il a toutes les qualités d'un ras-le-bol
qui pète au lit ouais ah ça c'est déjà
peut-être une bonne nouvelle bon
attention ce chrono
[Musique]
non
oui
on imagine très bien jean luc romero
dansant des nuits entières sont donnés
sonneurs et donc évidemment il la
connaît s'en souvient c'est un peu plus
dur maintenant attention à ça dit
abdullah attention mais fermes au salon
et
[Musique]
il
hu
les
j'ai même génération ça allait c'est pas
le cas c'est la génération c'est la
guerre
bon élève et en même temps voilà c'est
bien paul anka bravo attention paulo
cesar
on
sk us ou flash
j'ai dit serge on s'était tous rapide je
t'aime quelque temps je sais bien qu'un
fond le shakespeare le déficit a repris
là ça reprend mercredi way le 15 au
palais des glaces à 21h30 sur rien c'est
tout shakespeare en combien de temps en
90 minutes ses patients non c'est une
façon attention to be or not to be
attention parle jamais
[Musique]
ripley ripley dans la région entendu
j'ai entendu le garçon qui était assis
derrière blondeur d'abord pour moi pour
moi yacine l'âge et le point bas l'a
ensuite j'ai entendu volant d'heures qui
a répété ce qu'il avait encore dû
et après j loin qu'à répéter ce que le
landais achmed pour la remettre l'armé
non serge on peut regarder quand même on
regarde en l'air mais les plaies
ouais
tapez 2
oh
c'est un joint aux annonceurs je peux
pas dire ça quand même
il ya eu soufflage bas c'est toi qui as
soufflage le point 20 équipes mais
bérénice béjo
je t'avais dit soulagé les autres à
temps mais moi tu as une cote avec
catherine barma
c'est pas vrai tu peux tu peux lui
demander tout ce que tu veux c'est un
vrai catherine c'est vrai on peut alors
ok je crois que catherine on va
s'arranger à d et es et open
ces normes et 86 mais le vannetais n'ont
pas longtemps
attention par l'eau allait là
[Musique]
ça lui est arrivé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à un coûteux spell on you nicoletta la
chanson de rizal simone acheter ce
qu'ils m'ont jay hawkins je sais pas par
l'eau
[Applaudissements]
reste bon marché avoir un branchement ce
garçon à tous les dons forcée de leur
colonie géo crimine jay hawkins pelouse
nice a été chanté aussi par nina simone
verdier et par nicoletta comme vous
l'avez si bien remarquer ma chère
florence
je vous félicite qu est-ce qui lui dit
son père quand elle fait un truc comme
ça hein quitte à avoir une fille autant
que je sois gel
merci c'était l'enfer
jeudi nous oblige un regard
la télévision avec michael c
avocat olivier morice
perdre ici une leçon de savoir vivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à 18
lancement
alors à perdre
kaba ces deux élus
fichiers achetés vivait là messieurs
didier gustin merci
les bébés
en attendant gustin en tournée le 17
janvier à bois-colombes 18 à marolles
leurs cadres à bagneux et le 1er mars à
mai
daniel thomas daniel gambade
interlocuteur privilégié
j'ai protégé mitterrand s'est délité
jean claude lattès à la barre
ça ne nous
tu fais
et grâce et vous
d'avoir abordé la contradiction jean luc
romero merci les gars
vj woodyatt donne d'ailleurs merci merci
d'avoir été là
les jours 24 heures de la vie d'une
femme de lamboeny qu'avec des
[Musique]
et messieurs 2 0 + l'intense d'origine
c'est chez naïve voilà martin roy
l'homme s'appelle marc lavoine
le single elle est créatrice appel
quelle est ma permanence
jusqu'en mars 2003 le siège
le 18 à villepinte du maintien
la fia et le 30 janvier à nancy le 31
la plus porteurs
sans frontières edouard boubat pour la
liberté de la presse reporters sans
frontières alors
ray mais vous dire que lundi soir à 20h
ça
les nouvelles émissions déjà présent pas
tant est qu'ils se mêlent tribu
vous soyez l'habitat merde j'ai perdu
dix matches salut à lundi
mo
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
c'est remarquable
[Applaudissements]